okay seeing as though the time is now 9
36 I'm going to open this work session
on Monday March 20th so for the record
uh those of you in the audience and at
home I'm representative Maureen Mooney
the vice chair of division three our
chairman representative Jess Edwards is
at a meeting right now so he'll be
running a few minutes late to our work
session
so just to sort of recap we had a very
productive day in my opinion last Friday
we actually went through 48 items was my
count in terms of items in it House Bill
2 to discuss and take some preliminary
votes on where we were leaning with
regard to those items
several of the items have been put off
on hold until we get more information
which we hope to gather today and then
some other items will certainly be
voting on for sure to take an accurate
count of where we stand on those
all right as for today we have a work
session starting now and then we do have
a full Finance exec session starting at
one o'clock in this room 18 bills to be
exec starting at one o'clock today
representative talerski
thank you madam chair do you know
um what the plan is for our division are
we going to reconvene after that full
exec session thank you for that that's
come up uh before this morning so you're
the second person to mention that I
don't know the answer I will ask
chairman Edwards if we could convene
immediately after that session exact
session okay
all right so with that anything further
from the members of the committee today
to take up or discuss at this time okay
thank you then I'm going to ask Mr
Ripple who promised us last Friday and
as always came through today with an
update of where we stand based on our
discussions on House Bill 2. so that has
now been distributed to everyone it's
far more colorful and filled in than it
was early on Friday so that means
progress is being made Mr Ripple if
you'd like to discuss that handout
sure yes as you mentioned most of the
items have been grayed out if they're
grayed out that means they were
tentatively decided on on Friday you
will notice in the action column
a few different annotations if it's on
hold that's pretty obvious if you're
keeping it that's pretty obvious
everything that's being either replaced
or deleted will have an amendment
associated with it if that amendment is
ready I the amendment number is shown
there and I'll be putting those all
online this afternoon
in some cases there were some deletions
there was a decision to make something
permanent I don't yet have an amendment
ready for that so the number is to be
determined but I will have one shortly
um
so I'm not sure if you wanted to start
with the items that are on hold or if
you wanted to move on to house build one
I'm good with moving on to House Bill
one and distributing that and just
getting the overview I think the sooner
the members see that the better does
anybody disagree okay
will have that distributed and then give
us the overview there then next up I was
thinking we could get some follow-ups on
the Choose Love program number item 212
and also it was emailed to all of the
members information on the sununu youth
center
Mr ribson perhaps a discussion from you
also for the members I Melissa Saint
Seer I'm told is coming today she's the
legal counsel for the Department of
Health and Human Services she's able to
be here at 10 15 and of course has a
busy schedule so I'm going to suggest to
Chairman Edwards that we hear from her
as soon as she comes in to discuss some
follow-up items we had from last Friday
so if
I don't mention it right away at 10 15
if she's here and someone else sees her
by all means bring it up so we can hear
from her early on
okay Mr Ripple how about that house bill
one
sheet
and I did actually give away my copy so
yeah I I can pull it up on my computer
it's no big deal just it'll just take me
House Bill 2 tracking sheet uh if the
committee has made a decision you can
see that it's been grayed out
uh so on line two for example the
Department's technical requests have
been grayed out and those are approved
on March 13th
the agency prioritized needs requests
remain unacted on
when we get down to the agency other
request starting on line 14 there are
three yet to be acted on
and then down below that
we have the various divisions within HHS
so I want to make sure that all of those
were on here so we could go through them
one by one uh perhaps later today to see
if anyone had any proposed changes that
are not reflected on this sheet as of
now the only items reflected on here are
a few such as Medicaid rate increases
that are outstanding the alcohol fund
that are outstanding and the county cap
so that is the sheet and I don't know if
anyone has any questions about that
okay thank you for that any questions
regarding the house bill one sheet or
the house bill two sheet distributed
today
okay thank you
Miss Fox if I could just trouble you to
turn the lights on over there I hate to
see our audience in the
she's the light person
right I'm sorry about that thank you
okay thank you any other questions
thoughts on House Bill one or two sheet
very good all right with that and with
no objection I'm going to ask Mr ribson
to come forward and discuss where we
left off regarding items 77 to 78 in
house bill 2. related once again to the
construction of a new Youth Detention
Center
just to refresh everyone's memories we
had some follow-up points related to
that house bill 2 item
Mr White promised he would get the
appropriate experts here on the subject
they're they're here so we'll hear from
them now on that so welcome as always Mr
ribson to division three and start when
ready
so much good morning Joe ribsome
director dcyf and I'm here with Nathan
Nathan white Chief Financial Officer
DHHS
and we do have at the request of the
committee last week information about
the budget breakdown has been disrupted
Kevin's got it okay so Kevin will be
bringing that around and I'll probably
hold on a minute until you have it to
this relates to the 2425 budget is that
correct that's not not the future budget
but the
the next this buy-in this coming
biennium
okay not the new new structure okay
great and does everybody have it yes
okay so you'll notice one um this is
slightly different than what was
distributed on Friday what was
distributed on Friday was right we start
our budget process a year ago and what
we distribute on Friday is what we had a
year ago but there's been a lot of
change over the past year so when I sat
down with our budget staff Friday
afternoon and kind of went line by line
through it I realized it didn't quite
make sense anymore given the changes
over the past year
so a few things that this committee is
already aware of that have changed over
the past year right the education
structure is now different it's now
contracted because the Educators have
retired we've also over the past year
had to flip different positions from
full time to part-time because we
couldn't fill things but we were able to
get part-time people to come in and
we've had to reclass a couple things in
order to make sure that we're able to
get people to take those positions
reclassify them so the budget that was
presented Friday was no longer accurate
for what the position what the facility
looks like today so we updated it here
so you'll notice the numbers are
slightly different but their Rel the
total lines are pretty much the same
um
you'll see the I think what's the
difference there I think it is it's just
about a five go ahead in in the first
what
in the first year it's approximately
five thousand dollars less than what was
included in section 223 of hb2 and in
the second year it's approximately
so that's what you see in front of you
in the chart to the upper left to the
right you see the different remaining
positions within the facilities are not
all filled positions but these are all
the funded positions within the facility
and then at the bottom you see the
breakdown of the contracts that make up
the medical line that I was asked to
provide more detail on so
um I'm happy to start wherever folks
want me to start
um maybe I'll start with the medical
line because that's the easiest thing
so what that's comprised of is a
relatively small long-term contract with
Catholic Medical Center it says for labs
it's for you know anytime we got to get
tests done of kids things like that
um
you know we have a contract with them
they don't charge an awful lot to us for
that purpose and it's a on as needed
basis we don't pay them that amount of
money we pay them the cost of the
whatever service that they're provided
and it's always less than that twenty
seven thousand dollar number that's in
there for the full year for all the kids
in the facility
the next the big item here is the
Dartmouth contract it says medical staff
what that actually is is you'll recall
from prior conversations that we moved
the clinical staff from being sysc
employees to being Dartmouth contracted
employees so with that contract includes
is a part-time psychiatrist a full-time
psychologist
two licensed clinicians
and a pediatrician who comes in a couple
hours a week to do rounds on the kids
who works at another facility in
Manchester a couple days a week and he
stops by sysc in the morning to do that
so that big cost item is actually
reflective of some things that used to
be State positions that we've moved into
this contract with Dartmouth in order to
get licensed staff to do the work with
kids
dental hygienist and dentist are the
other two lines there again we pay them
on kind of an hourly basis we don't pay
them that full amount but it's based on
how often they have to come in to work
with the kids that are in the building
and then the other category is just kind
of for other times where we need to
bring a kid out for medical care that's
kind of a one-off and you know you can't
always have a contract in place for
every possible medical issue you can
imagine that a child might have so this
is the funding source that's used to pay
for those things if a kid needs physical
therapy or if you know they need an
x-ray or something like that that's not
part of the other services that's where
that comes from and this is all General
funds because on as of now under federal
law you're not allowed to use Medicaid
for kids who are detained and committed
I think I mentioned to the committee
that there is a change coming to the
Medicaid rules in the next couple years
which is going to allow Medicaid to be
used for detained kids but it's not
entirely clear how broad that's going to
be right if that can be you know if it's
just for discrete services or anything
else they haven't kind of defined what
that means but I think we will see some
relief at least on the detained inside I
believe it's in this Federal fiscal year
2025 budget that that change occurs I
could be wrong but I think that's that's
when it is
um the Staffing up to the top
you'll see here the total is a little
less than we saw in the one before
um because some of those positions have
now moved into part-time positions
reason being you know we were desperate
to hire youth counselors in particular
if we needed a part-time if somebody was
willing to work part-time we were happy
to take them part-time because we needed
anybody that we could get right so there
were some other positions like that too
such as challenges with when we lost
kitchen staff and we couldn't hire
somebody to help in the kitchen but
somebody was willing to do that work
part-time we were creating positions to
allow for that I will say that's one of
the benefits of having this with an hb2
instead of hb1 is that it does give us
flexibility to be a little more Nimble
around what budget lines things are
occurring in right so for example when
the teachers all left and we had to
quickly enter into a contract because we
had the flexibility to move money in
that whole big pot of hb2 we were able
to do that without having to come back
to Joint fiscal and get approval to be
able to create a to be able to move
money between lines to be able to fund a
contract so there is some benefit to
that flexibility especially when we're
in a period as we are right now where
this this facility is still frankly from
a staffing perspective relatively
unstable
another example of that is we currently
have a contract with a staffing
organization Maxim they bring in
contracts for 18 Temps at a time
there's part of the provision is that is
that we can convert those staff from
temps to full-time staff I am pleased to
say that we've actually since the
actions that happened a few weeks ago
stabilizing the future of sysc
a handful of Maxim staff who wanted to
become full-time YC's but were anxious
to do so have decided to move over so we
actually do have a few more YC's today
and we have some more in the pipeline so
we are seeing some progress from that
but that contract really paid for out of
unused salary dollars right we don't
have a separate contract bucket in the
budget for that so that's the type of
thing that might be challenging in a
future years by moving to hb1 if we
don't have that type of flexibility we'd
have to come back to join fiscal in
order to move money from Line to Line to
to be a little more Nimble with things
like that
um and yeah I think that's that's
broadly what I wanted to say and then
I'll just stop and see if folks have
questions
thank you Mr ribson and I believe I
misspoke previous this is related to
item 223 in house bill 2.
I I said an earlier section
previous so item 223 House Bill 2. okay
questions representative tolerski for
question thank you madam chair thank you
director for taking my question
um
on the bottom the medical costs you
answered my question first of all was I
was shocked to see number one that the
kids aren't covered under Medicaid and
number two just the the bottom line and
how expensive that is is that are those
numbers set costs regardless of the
number of kids
and are they more like a like a contract
to hold them
when needed so the bulk of it the
Dartmouth contract pays for salaries of
individuals right so when those
positions are filled they are set costs
so and right now for the first time in
years those positions are all filled so
as of last month we have the two
clinicians the psychiatrist the
part-time psychiatrist the full-time
psychologist and the pediatrician who
comes in a couple hours a week so those
costs are really set costs if they're
all filled in the past year or so there
have been huge vacancies there right we
didn't have both of our clinicians until
just a month ago and honestly we didn't
even have any of our clinicians it was
just our psychologist for almost a year
because it took them that long to find
somebody to come into the facility
especially with all the ambiguity about
the future of it so in the past year or
so it hasn't been spent to its fullest
but going forward with those positions
filled I would expect it to be fully
spent the other contracts are all on
kind of a per use basis right there's a
there's a rate depending on what the the
hourly rate for example for the
hygienist and the dentist and for the
labs it's based on the cost of the labs
and our experience with Catholic medical
centers they're pretty they're pretty
generous with us they're not trying to
to overcharge us so those smaller
contracts are variable depending on
usage okay that answers my question
thank you yep
and and just to follow up on that um for
my Contracting perspective so each of
those contracts they have a fixed price
limitation which is reflected here
within the budget so if if some if these
lines were to be reduced we would have
to go back and amend the standing
contract uh potentially because those
those funds are planned to be encumbered
representative Stringham for a question
followed by representative Wallner
uh so something that's not in this
budget that I'd like you to comment on
is the intake process for kids
regardless of I think any kid that comes
in has to have have
um a full search and a large number of
other things that are going through as
part of the intake process
and
um part of the invasive search is
maybe you can comment on what that is
but and
um
you know I wanted to bring up uh or ask
your opinion if there's anything we can
do in the budget so uh the intake
process is less chromatic and less
invasive and um you know I'll let you
describe
um what's going on and talk from there
sure thank you for the question yes so
um when a youth is detained or committed
at sysc
um there's a process that's followed
um there is a what we call a sally port
in the back for those of you who have
been there or not right it's a garage
that opens up law enforcement pulls in
with the youth it locks behind them the
youth is then brought into the facility
at that point they're met by a few
different folks typically a clinical
person
a youth counselor and a nurse and before
that youth is processed further
throughout the building the nurse um
well one of the very first thing that
happens is they actually have to do and
I think what representative Stringham is
getting at is they do a strip search of
the youth to make sure they're not
bringing anything into the facility
that's potentially dangerous they don't
do a cavity search but they do do a
strip search that's always done under
law by somebody of the same sex or by a
medical staff if there's not a same-sex
person available although typically
there is somebody available
um but in the rare instance that there
wouldn't be would be a medical staff
that would do that
um the other part of the process
includes a full medical kind of overview
by the nurse
um in the next day or so when the
physician comes in the physician will
also do a full review unless there's
some type of immediate situation that
needs to be remedied that the nurse
identifies on their initial screening
clinical does typically immediate same
day kind of cursory review with the
child over their clinical needs to try
to make some decisions about where the
best place for that trout to go is
within the facility who are the best
peers for them to be with and to start
to set up you know initial clinical
support and planning for that young
person we have a part-time Pastor in the
facility that Pastor does a religious
Services review with a young person when
they come in to see you know if they
identify of any religion and if there's
any type of religious services that
they're going to want to have access to
while they're in the building and the
pastor's job is to make sure that that's
available regardless of what faith the
child is it's it's all denominational
even though the pastor themselves is a
Christian pastor
um
what are the other key Parts those are
the biggest key parts that are coming to
mind I think what representative string
was particularly referring to is as we
went through is he and and another
member came through a tour of the
facility a month or so ago our
psychologist was talking about how that
strip search process can be traumatic
for kids particularly for some of these
kids who are
um who are you know particularly
vulnerable and may themselves have been
victim of sex abuse in the past and the
idea an idea that was floated was
something that's done in other
facilities around the country which is
using instead of a strip search a I
don't know what the right word is but
essentially a a scanner similar to what
you see in airports right so you
wouldn't have to actually have the
youths physically Strip This actually
happens not only on intakes but also
every time a court has to leave every
time a youth has to leave the building
so if a youth has to go to court when
they come back they go through that same
process if a youth we don't see a whole
lot of furloughs anymore because the
youth are there for such a short period
of time but sometimes we do so if youth
goes on a furlough to spend you know an
afternoon with with Mom or whatever when
they come back they go through that
process if they leave to go to the
doctor's office when they come back they
go through that process to ensure the
safety in the building so that was an
idea that was that was raised by our
clinical staff as a way to minimize or
reduce some of the trauma that our young
folks experience when they come in the
building that being said I don't have
information on what the actual cost of
doing something like that is we haven't
um do you know if if you did acquire and
and utilize an instrument like that
whether it would be applicable uh to
would you be able to transfer to the new
center yeah I believe so and would you
still need it there yeah I believe so
um uh I believe we
we're looking in the ballpark of a half
a million dollars for such a piece
that's what I was told but I haven't
thoroughly researched it so I'd want to
you know I if folks are interested in
that information I'm happy to go back
and and do some research and see what
they cost I do know that they're used in
other facilities around the country so
you know it's not something we'd be able
to figure that out
um you know you know if if you continue
is it okay to continue I'm sorry the um
if you continue to have Staffing
shortfalls is it possible there would be
uh money that could be moved from the
permanent Services class to pay for
something like that in this two-year
window it's possible but it's hard to
say because that same class is also
being used to pay for the temp contract
right now and it's also being used to
supplement the overtime
um
portion of the budget because we've been
paying so much overtime to have staff
from all over DHHS come in to pick up
shifts at sysc because we are so short
staffed on that youth counselor so I I'm
not sure that that would be there you
know but it's you know
possible
so that's what I was going to ask if
you're if you're short staffed or the
temp service rates higher and you
mentioned overhead too because we
actually appropriated additional money
for this year
even though Staffing levels were were
below the authorized level by a lot so
um and is there any any other
explanation other than that's where the
additional money was being filled in for
I'm sorry the question was 2023 for the
2023 1.5 million why was that yeah so
there's really two big issues one was
Staffing was so low so we had to use a
lot of overtime and not just from within
um sysc but from throughout DHHS at
large in order to keep keep the facility
staffed well enough to be safely
operating and frankly we have to staff
more heavily when we're in this
situation than when we have our when we
have our own kind of full-time staff who
are very experienced and really know the
youth because it's just you know if they
don't know the youth really well they
don't know their triggers really well we
just need more of a presence in the
building to make sure that we can keep
things safe so stabilizing the workforce
would actually help drive down the
number of people you need in the
building at any given time the other big
piece of it was that we did not renew
the contract with Vermont so in the last
budget there was a significant amount of
money that was anticipated to come in
from a contract with Vermont where
Vermont was sending us their youth to
care for it as ISC as our own Staffing
situation got worse and worse I had to
tell Vermont that we were going to no
longer accept their children because you
know we had to worry about our kids
first and then when the opportunity came
for that contract to be renewed in
October we chose not to not to renew
that contract so in the last budget
there were funds that Revenue that was
anticipated that actually was not
realized
and and it was appropriated in the
amount of about 900 a little over nine
hundred thousand dollars in state fiscal
year 23.
in in Revenue that did not materialize
um is that something
uh with the stabilization that you're
considering going back to I don't think
it would make much sense for us to go
back to serving kids from another state
you know it's
not saying it could never happen but it
just doesn't seem to make a lot of sense
especially when we're moving towards it
seems like constructing a smaller
facility which where we'd be moving so I
really would prefer our Focus over the
next couple years to be around how do
you stabilize that Workforce and make
those transitions with our own Workforce
and staff and models working with kids
to be ready to move into that new
facility in a few years rather than you
know opening up the doors and serving
kids from the region
does this budget provide you with the
flexibility to do that if you want to do
it so it the resources are in here to do
other than buying the the machine that
we were talking about the resources are
in here to do that like I said the
flexibility is a little bit challenging
the way that hb1 typically works because
if we need to move money say from the
permanent class line to an overtime line
or to a contract line we don't have that
flexibility the way that this is the way
that HP one typically works now there
might be a remedy to that right whether
that's through hb2 or through some
special language to give us Authority or
the other remedy of course is that we
come back to Joint fiscal to get
authority to move the money between the
lines whenever we have to make those
changes but I would say
the situation is still relatively
unstable and I do anticipate that we're
going to have to continue to make rapid
changes to keep up with the needs of the
facility over the next year or so until
we really get the workforce stable
core president walner had a question
I just was wondering on the medical if a
child comes into the facility who has an
ongoing medical issue does the child's
Insurance health insurance either
Medicaid or private insurance continue
private insurance does Medicaid has to
be suspended when the young person
enters the facility under federal law so
if the young youth has private insurance
that could continue to be used for those
resources but if it's Medicaid it has to
be suspended the way that we do this is
It's not their Medicaid is not
terminated but suspended for the time
that they're in the facility and if they
are out of the facility even for one
overnight if they're admitted to a
hospital say for a physical treatment
thing or even a mental health thing or
whatever and they're admitted overnight
we can actually turn the Medicaid back
on for that stay but then once they
return to the facility it gets suspended
again but the the key is that they have
to be admitted overnight so if they go
for a treatment a day treatment that
doesn't allow you to turn the Medicaid
back on it has to be an overnight
admission
okay and what about if they were on a
prescription
same same thing with the prescriptions
the Medicaid won't cover it while
they're in the building private
insurance would cover it while they're
in the building okay thank you
but isn't it true also though that if
they need pharmacies uh if Medicaid's
not paying for it they don't have
private insurance the state will write
the check to pay for the pharmacies yes
we do have it's interestingly it's
actually just not in this budget line
but there is a contract with a pharmacy
for that exact purpose all right thank
you uh representative tolorski
thank you I'm wondering if you could um
share if a strip search of these youth
falls into the guidelines of
trauma-informed Care and Rehabilitation
you know I it's certainly not the most
trauma-informed approach you know it's
one of those things when you're running
a facility like this that you're
balancing safety security and treatment
right and it's one of the kind of
tensions within within the juvenile
justice system as a whole
um so yes I mean finding an alternative
to that would be ideal but I think
eliminating that without having an
alternative in place would be very
dangerous
I'm sorry I missed your presentation
um
I I I do have a question it still feels
like for for what we're doing 84 total
head count is is a lot and I'm just
curious you know how it is we're still
so high 80 I guess it's 89
and whether or not
this deployment of personnel supports
the idea that we really want to begin an
active transition to the new model right
yeah so
um the you know the a lot of these
positions are positions that are you
know maintenance kitchen things like
that that may not be necessary in a new
facility if we were to move into a
co-located model so you would bring that
down
um I do think right the front line staff
are pretty close to where they need to
be you know at least until we see a lot
of stabilization and can kind of
reevaluate that
um and that's really the bulk of it
right the 45 youth counselors and their
supervisors are the bulk of the of the
positions
um so for I think there was a question
that was asked last time that I didn't
include here that I can speak through
which is right our staffing patterns
during the day and I'm sure when I go
through this people are going to say
this feels high but I do believe it's
necessary so the typical Staffing
Baseline Staffing at the facility for
waking hours is for every unit that's
operational you want to have two YC's
two youth counselors so a unit right
typically a normal day with nothing at
all unusual happening which those are
very rare days you would have one female
unit and two male units running so
that's three units running that's six
youth counselors
then you need to have one youth
counselor who's on float to provide
breaks to folks so that's seven youth
counselors one youth counselor who works
in what we call the bubble the control
room to operate video security cameras
um
uh doors exit in entrance and exit
things like that that person's in there
so that brings you up to eight youth
counselors for the purpose of of
managing those three units and then you
do supervisor on duty so that's nine is
kind of your typical Staffing
there's other things that often happen
that then exacerbate that and need
additional staff right so if we have a
young person that needs to go to
a medical appointment a YC or sometimes
two YC's needs to accompany accompany
them to that if we have a young person
who is in the medical unit which happens
all the time now because we're still
operating on kind of covid light
protocols which include that when a
young person comes into the facility
they stay in medical and get a covid
test and remain there until it comes
back clear at which point they're
integrated with the rest of the
population so while there's a young
person in medical you need staff to be
with that young person in medical if you
have a young person who's on an a watch
like a suicide watch A B and C are the
different levels of watches we have
those young people require one-to-one
supervision to make sure that they
remain safe if we have a young person
who's on the crisis stabilization unit
because they've had an escalation which
puts you know themselves or others at
risk that's then an additional one or
two staff that you need to monitor that
young person on the crisis stabilization
unit so when I talk about the Baseline
waking hour Staffing of being typically
eight YC's that's two per floor one in
central control and one on float plus a
supervisor the truth is on most days you
end up needing more than that so your
Staffing is really Dynamic right you
kind of schedule it to assume you that
you need that plus one but if on a given
day you see that things are going you
know different than expected then you
need to start pooling more people in to
make sure you can safely cover all those
changes that happen in a day
um
it gets particularly complex at this
moment where we're working with a whole
lot of temp staff and or
external staff internal to DHHS but
external to sysc who don't have as much
experience and understanding of the
population
that exacerbates the situation as well
in terms of being able to make sure you
have enough people in the building so at
the end of the day what you end up
looking like is a staffing ratio that's
close to one staff to two or one staff
to one and a half youth in the building
and again I'm sure some people are going
to say that seems like a a really
really high Staffing level I would say
given the the needs and Acuity of our
youth and the experience that we had
just this past year when our staffing
levels were below that I really worry
about having those Staffing levels um
not get you know go below that okay so
that was a lot of explanation of and
justification of the Personnel I
appreciate that uh are there any
national benchmarks that you consult or
could replace the analysis that you just
provided us
so the only real National Benchmark is
the so-called Prius standard the prison
rape elimination act standard
um that Benchmark is I think wholly
inappropriate and it's really designed
to ensure that youth are not being
sexually assaulted it has nothing to do
with providing trauma-informed care or
anything else that's
um that Benchmark is one to eight I'd
also comment that that is a benchmark
that is established looking at
facilities that are far less acute than
our facility is
um you know you have lots of states
around the country that incarcerate
children at a high far higher rate than
we do for very very not serious offenses
right things like shoplifting things
like graffiti things that we would never
have a child come to sysc for and those
kids are just kidding I'm sorry I just
know that we're pressed for time and we
have a lot on the agenda I just want to
hear I think you may have missed
answering the question of if if we end
up
directing
legislatively that the transition to the
new model of the trauma-informed
therapeutic-based Care be provided that
this Manpower and this budget is will
support that direction and you don't you
won't need additional money you won't
need okay no not at all from a staffing
perspective certainly not and actually
in fact there are there is some money in
this budget to actually inform to start
allow us to start to do the training and
support for the evidence-based models
that we do want to bring into the
facility thank you are there other
questions
representative walner
just wondered is
is
um
fashion or an accredited I mean
hospitals are accredited nationally all
kinds of facilities and child care
facilities earthquake is there no no
accrediting for there's there's not kind
of a national standard or crediting for
juvenile
detention and commitment facilities
around the country there are a couple
private entities one called Performance
Based standards or something like that
that people contract with that'll come
in and do kind of quality assurance
checks but I wouldn't call that a
National Standard there is also the
National Council of Juvenile Justice
administrators which basically is a
group of people that are me and my
counterparts in other states who put out
some kind of guidance around stuff like
that but again nothing that I would call
a National Standard because every state
is wildly different in how they how
these facilities work and who actually
goes to these facilities
thank you
okay uh I I got here in Midstream I
apologize representative Stringham uh
yeah just one thing I want you know one
share with you we had a discussion about
that about uh how all um
uh use that entered the facility uh both
first time and certain other times have
a full strip search and we had talked
about
um possibly
um whether there might be a possibility
of of supplementing the budget or moving
uh funds from one budget line item to
another to have equipment in the youth
center that would obviate the need to do
that so
um and um we we haven't added discussion
about it as a group
um
we there's possibility we could actually
get a quote for a piece of equipment or
something maybe to integrate with this
budget cycle and there may even be grant
opportunities that we haven't you know
I've heard in the past there have been
grant opportunities for things like this
it's just nothing that you know I don't
know enough about it right now to
so so not having heard that conversation
I'm I'm sympathetic to the the dignity
part of this and the preservation of
individual autonomy and dignity I you
know I think in your testimony you also
suggested that we have a public safety
imperative as well are there any pieces
of equipment that you know of that could
totally replace a a body cavity search
to make sure that we're not bringing
things onto the premises yeah and so we
don't currently do a cavity search we do
do a strip search though
and there are facilities around the
country that instead of doing a strip
search use a piece of equipment similar
to what you see in the airports right
um I don't know what those pieces of
equipment are called but there are
facilities around the country so I'm
going to take that as yes there there
are equipment that you know of that
could do an adequate job to make sure
we're ensuring Public Safety and so I
think I would Echo representative
stringham's point and I assume people in
the committee would be very interested
in in what it would take to get that
equipment to obviate the strip search
sure all right so so one way one might
we hear about that I mean we got to
finish our budget tomorrow I can I can
try to go back as soon as I get out of
here and and put staff to the task of of
investigating that all right did you
have a question today I was simply going
to um
reinforce that I'd love to see some
numbers and I apologize for the fast
turnaround but I think it's extremely
important based on our intent to
continue with trauma
um
informed care
very good represent or excuse me Mr wine
sorry I I also just want to point out
that um there's not only the initial
purchase price but we would also need an
ongoing service agreement as well
um just so the committee's not not
surprised when when we do bring those
numbers forward
all right I are there any other
questions on this subject
um if if not I'm not seeing any so uh
thank you for your testimony do you have
anything else for us I don't I don't
want to interrupt some other portion of
your presence I mean I did bring it just
based on a prior question I brought
information about the current kind of
clinical programming because somebody
asked me to bring that for today I'm
happy to go through that or if we don't
need to talk in the interest of time
let's just hand it out because I don't
know oh representative walner go ahead I
do have one one other question sure
the the program Choose Love
do you use that program yes
yeah and I believe there's folks here um
who can speak about that so at sysc we
have a handful of groups that we do
throughout the week with all the youth
there one of them is the choose love
social emotional learning program Choose
Love is actually short for the the Jesse
Lewis Choose Love movement Jesse Lewis
was a seventh grader who was killed
um during the Connecticut school
shooting years back and his mother made
it her mission to try to bring social
emotional learning to schools and other
types of programs with the idea of
reducing School violence and other types
of violence and uh we have a we have
that at sysc but it is also used
throughout dcyf throughout the schools
throughout actually adult corrections
even uses it and local law enforcement
um yeah so we'll delay the rest of that
conversation uh leave us a copy and
we'll just let folks know if they have
questions about it they can contact you
um so we're about at the point where the
the counselor uh Sierra
um missier is supposed to arrive and
come provide some testimony about some
language and she's not here right now
and I'm a little reluctant to get into
this be something else because her time
is is very limited
um so what I think I'll do at this point
is I'm just going to call a five minute
recess we're going to be done we're
going to be back in five minutes and if
she walks in sooner I'm going to just
ask that we get started sooner all right
oh so
um we're going to get started here in
about 60 seconds and hope hopefully my
voice goes over to the Dem caucus so
that they can hear that we're going to
start in 60 seconds could you go knock
on their door just let them know that we
want to because they're probably around
oh okay
um my my priority for time is when
Melissa Saint Sierra comes in I'm going
to try to get her to to the front of the
mic but I I believe we have great
representation here from the Choose Love
program so if you could come read your
name into the record and tell us what we
thank you my name is Shannon deslitz I'm
the program director of choose love for
the State of New Hampshire thank you I
know you have tons on your plate and
time limitations thank you for for being
open to hear me I wanted to share what
choose love is I think there's some
misconception a little bit about this
this did start here in 2018 as part of
our school safety preparedness task
force this became a highlight of that
report in backbone for proactive
preventative strategies
it initially started in our schools but
is expanded to various State departments
which Joe ribsum alluded to
why is comprehensive why is
comprehensive programming so important
for prevention of school violence it
disrupts the pathway Pathway to violence
changing School culture preventing a
grievance from happening in the first
place or if one does happen we are
providing skills and tools to work
through that
I am here today as someone who also
spoke who also specializes in
post-trauma therapy I've been providing
post-trauma therapy in Newtown Sandy
Hook for the last 10 years
it is every tier that I've wiped down
there every story that I know that I
can't share with you that fuels me here
in our state of New Hampshire I will do
everything in my power that I possibly
can to prevent any of our communities
from enduring what this community has
gone through the need for help 10 years
later doesn't go away in the write-up
that you have there is also testimony
from Daniel Jewish lead investigator
from the Sandy Hook school shooting
and sharing why he feels true's love is
as I said this spread Beyond School
balls former associate Commissioner of
DHHS Christine Tappen brought Scarlett
Lewis the creator of the program and me
in to present to 200 mid-level managers
of DHHS
because we have just a little bit of
time
uh what the the question that's been uh
I've been curious about is exactly what
is the the human touch point on somebody
who we're trying to help I don't I'd
like to just understand how we identify
that individual in need how we
interact with them how we measure
success could if you could just like
tell us about the the program at the
personal level right well quite frankly
this is for all ages any one of us okay
this is not just for children this is
for us big kids too this is getting to
the foundation and providing skills and
tools that are essential life skills
that we all need whether it be for
conflict resolution
um relationship skills social skills as
Joe redson alluded to this is used at
sysc we also utilize this at our
department of corrections
um Perry Plummer made sure that I was
introduced to commissioner Hanks we have
now become the first in the nation to
launch choose up for Corrections
feedback that we've received there we
just recently had the first graduating
class of the men's facility the women's
facility last year
was that this has given them skills and
tools to better themselves it is
increasing positive engagement with
um hopefully this will
change the course of their families
going forward it is helping them provide
positive engagement and helping others
within the walls as well we have also
modified this for transitional housing
units as well I I love your passion I
love that you know so much about the
program and again because of the
interest of time I'm just looking for
real specifics sure in terms of how we
identify who's in need how we try to
what kinds of things we provide and how
do we know what the metrics are on
whether or not we're succeeding sure
well this is for communities and homes
right and when you look at the stats
that are out there we're in a mental
health crisis substance misuse is up
anxiety depression is up suicidal
ideation is up we this gets to the root
cause of that this gets to the root
cause of all of these things when you
look at also in your packet for instance
okay for Spalding residential facility
when you look at the impact this has had
in children there with behavioral
challenges
we're looking at 84 aggressions per week
and one student down to less than five
105 physical aggressions per week down
to less than one
I have heard feedback from those that
are implementing this in their homes and
schools thank goodness we have this
because this has helped my child get
through the pandemic with these skills
no no you're telling me I should read
H2
on page two she outlined the Spalding
residential
um
data that they have pulled after
implementing the program
I didn't mean to speak out no no
you you've been around me enough to know
this is exactly the answer to my
question that I'm looking for so I'm I
do
so we can read these do you have
anything that any way in which you'd
want to summarize what's on the bottom
well I mean think think about
I mean that's pretty huge benefits right
so think about
the impact of that not just on the
children but the staff as well
and when we're thinking about retention
and burnout rates think about the
positive impact in that and going
forward I've had one student from that
Facility Who said choose love saved my
life if it wasn't for Choose Love I'd be
in jail
so
we need to think about Upstream
and prevention and proactive strategies
and this is why this program was created
in the first place this is why I was
you're doing a great job I'm sure and
I'm sorry to be asking you Financial
questions no I appreciate it it comes
with the territory I appreciate it
that's your job representative do you
have a question I do thank you Mr chair
and it's unfortunately a financial
question
you're probably the wrong person to
answer this however and maybe I'm
incorrect about this but my
understanding was this was in the
governor's office and I'm just wondering
why it doesn't just keep going there
well who's to say the next person corner
office is going to you know want to keep
this going forward and this is so we're
hi James Gary budget director I can help
answer that question uh what what the
government's office does really is they
don't have a lot of of policy uh
projects in that office we have a legal
office a budget office uh the policy
people who work with the legislature and
a in a group that handles uh constituent
complaints and that's about it uh what
this program was was something where uh
it was it was a test project to begin
with when Shannon came on in 2018
and uh the governor agreed to get it
started and to see about the merits of
it well the merits are such where uh
the our initial faith in the project has
been uh you know paid down a number of
times and the fact that uh we love the
way the project has developed in a way
it's going but to where it needs to go
now it's sort of like you have a pot of
a plant and now you need to put it in
your garden to let it grow to its
fullest and that's why we believe moving
in out of the governor's office into HHS
which has a lot of the uh
alignments that Choose Love could use to
have it grow even more and when I say
grow I don't mean financially I don't
mean spending more money or more staff
or adding a whole lot more to it I mean
because it's been since 2018 has grown
dramatically since then so it's really
just to have that project grow to its
fullest capability and that would not be
in the governor's office
so I understand that but apparently the
people are there the money is still
there you just said you don't need more
money why not just continue it there for
this biennium and then we don't have to
worry about this right now given our
other pressures that we have to deal
with
yeah well again we thought now's the
time is right we would have done this in
in 2020 uh except that was really the
the first budget coming out of uh for
the for the 20
223 fiscal year sorry and that would
have been that was really the first
budget coming out of covet and funds
were very limited and we haven't really
seen the full uh project expand to the
point where it has now so we feel Now's
the Time to do it uh it it could stay in
the governor's budget certainly
um however we feel that what the best
thing for the program is is to move it
over to HHS at this point yeah and I am
at the point where I am needing
administrative assistance it has grown
to that level and simultaneously that
this was brought forward I'm being
reached out by for instance Nashville
Public Health to Keynote at their
conference they are recognizing the
importance so so why do we want to move
this it comes down to the safety and
well-being of the citizens of New
Hampshire they deserve to be able to
deepen and broaden this even more
so to clarify I guess I misunderstood I
thought was just moving over with
without changing the budget so what is
the current budget in the governor's
office
what what it is it's it's adding one
additional staff member uh dollars
please uh it I believe it's roughly
is that a new hundred thousand if you're
adding a person that's almost sounds
like it's an incremental cost of the
person unless it's in the documents I'm
sure but What's the total amount that
that that's in the governor's office now
and what will it be if it if it hits the
department the his Department would be
250 000 that I'm positive of and I
believe the current budget is around 150
000. all right the the
um that money would be for my position
administrative assistant and also money
to put on events for people around New
Hampshire like we have done
okay so I want to just go back for a
moment to what you all actually do do
you do you from your office there in the
governor's office you don't actually
reach out and and touch any of these
clients directly you you're you're I am
out there I am doing presentations I am
doing workshops for instance
commissioner Quinn now has me doing
workshops for every division within
Department of Safety because he
recognizes the importance of this the
well-being of his own staff
um I am out there anytime anybody is
wanting something I am there right so we
used to call that in the military train
the trainer you're you're not the actual
Hands-On uh in person to integrate but
you're training all the workforce that
that would do that yeah it depends
what's what environment it is in going
into the schools and for instance and
introducing this to staff they then take
that and carry out and I am there to
support I do parent Community nights for
instance it's very important that we are
able to increase parent and community
engagement so that is my role
and then also working for instance with
Department of Corrections alongside cast
which is Universal Design for Learning
we are co-designing this program with
participants in the program so it's
ongoing with their feedback to make it
even better thank you representative
looked like you had a question I was
just going to say I know that the Nashua
School District has incorporated the
program and I've only heard positive
um enthusiastic support for it in our
city
all right go ahead representative thank
you so just to follow up and represent
uh chairman Edwards question you pointed
to the Spalding statistics so were you
the one that worked with those six
students no that was the staff there
so
did that have anything to do with you
well they I brought it to them and I
worked with them I emailed with the
principal on a weekly basis to check in
and support and see what else they might
need because they have rarely become
Champions with this so back to his
question did you train the trainers with
regard to that program specifically
thank you
okay
uh are there any other questions on
choose love I think we all should this
is a general rule we should uh because
that's what the world needs now is love
sweet love so yeah and on that all right
I'm not going to sing it for you
um but so thank you
um and uh we'll we'll be in touch thank
you so much thank you very much Mr
chairman and committee members
who's speaking
oh that was you okay I heard a
disembodied voice so all right so I
think because we're still waiting for Ms
sincere let's talk about TANF
can you Mr White bring us around I think
we wanted to talk about the
um the amount that we needed to make
sure that we met our minimum level of
effort
and we had kicked around you felt safe
with the three million was that 3
million a year you were you were
comfortable with the 3 million
and we were saying could you be
comfortable that our risk is mitigated
at a lower level
sure so um
I had sent Kevin I believe the week
prior
um a a document that detailed everywhere
where the TANF was budgeted within that
document
um off top of my head I believe there's
approximately 2.8 million dollars of
assumed Revenue so we to just just to
kind of start at the Baseline
within that document technically it gets
us there but we're not going to spend
all of those dollars that are budgeted
because we may not get all that Revenue
so that may not be available if we have
vacancies we're not going to aleft we're
not going to allocate TANF costs
um to to those positions if they are
vacant so we're gonna we're gonna need
to have dollars that we can spend
um most likely towards cash assistance
than we have in recent years
um seeing cash assistance going down
which was just kind of another X Factor
or risk associated with this
um I I went back
um and and looked at things I I I mean I
would be if if we reduced the the the
amounts from 3 million to say 2.5
million annually I I think that still
gives us
um enough of a safety net to make sure
that I can still hit that Moe
um but but that that that's kind of
where where I stand right now all right
representative and by the way thank you
for that all right because you could
have done the bureaucratic thing and
just to know I look at it I'm still at
three million so I I appreciate you
working with us so representative erf
thank you and thank you Mr White so
recently we talked about language about
down and you you know better than I do
um
uh you give me the opportunity to go
back to any funds otherwise appropriated
in the in the treasury or something of
that nature could something like that be
used here to bring it down to even lower
than two and a half million but still
giving you that flexibility this so so
TANF is a little trickier because our
maintenance and not not that I want to
complicate tanith anymore but our
maintenance of effort is actually done
uh on a on a different cycle than our
state fiscal year so that that may not
necessarily work as well and and what
representative erf is is referring to
we've had conversations about
um there's different agencies in the
department where where there has been an
hb2 provision that in the event uh
funding for this program is insufficient
uh the the department may go back to the
fiscal committee uh for for approval and
the governor May draw down funds
otherwise not uh not um not authorized
so essentially utilize General funds to
cover any potential shortfall I don't
know because of the complexities with
TANF where a lot of those costs are are
they're cost allocated the revenue the
timing of the revenues and whatnot I I
don't think this is a good candidate for
that solution
thank you for that
other other questions
okay so
um Mr Ripple uh trivia question for you
was was uh this conversation related to
uh section 253 that we had on hold
I think it was right yes it was okay so
uh so still not seeing uh our attorney
um
do does anyone want to make a proposal
on 253
uh what I I received a text from Melissa
sains there she'll be here at
approximately 11 o'clock oh okay good
thank you
I would propose we go with the 2.5
million if that's if uh
okay per year 2.5 or 2.8 what did you
say 2.5
per year per year
for years 24 and 25. to be clear
okay uh I is there any opposition
because I'd like to get us to where we
could straw vote this
yeah in the opposition to lowering this
to 2.5
so so we'll do a straw vote all all
those in favor of reducing the three
million dollars a year that for each
year from 3 million to 2.5 on Section
okay so that's eight to nothing
all right uh so thank you for your time
um Mr White I appreciate it and since
we're still holding off on
um
the immediate issue let's go to the
spreadsheet on hb2 uh this this looks
like a very nice spreadsheet where the
gray is meant to indicate those things
that on Friday we said we were okay the
things that are still in white are the
things that we need to come back to
there was one item on here that was
grayed out that we need to that I know
that we need to bring back to being
white and that is item
I think it's two two six
Health Care Facility workplace violence
prevention program
is is that we're not talking about now I
just want to make sure you you have that
Amendment ready to go I do oh okay so so
why don't you hand that Amendment out
and while you're doing that because we
are short time let's let's go to section
49 and 50. the juvenile peer-to-peer
grief support programming and this was
1.5 million in this using FY 23 money
um go ahead
it's the very top one on this sheet yeah
it's the the 49.50
okay now we kept this on hold and I had
such a weird weekend I don't remember
why we put it on hold who who who
amongst division three
um had had more questions or that they
I had no questions I wanted to delete it
do you you don't have any controversial
notes so was it just this was the first
one and we didn't know what we were
doing
okay okay all right all right you know
first step so yeah go ahead I would
suggest a straw vote to delete you want
to delete
um
is there any opposition to deleting
do you want to speak to that
representative Waller and then tolersky
well I would like to not delete it until
I
hear more about it I think we just
learned for instance
um from choose love that we we finally
we got some information about the
program and I would like to find out
what this one's about too before I
voting to delete it
go ahead got you spoke to this on on
Friday representative
I don't remember that at all she said
this hasn't been funded in the past but
she'd like to keep keep it going I mean
she definitely spoke to it
thank you oh maybe I'm in the wrong
place okay so so who do you recall
speaking to it uh um commissioner or
associate commissioner Fox I believe is
her last name Fox
is the name I remember do you remember
what she had to say about this line item
Mr White yes so so Katya had had spoken
to this this is a new program
um for this year
um she had indicated that that it would
it would likely um if this was
appropriated we would go out to bid uh
we'd probably an issue an RFP or an RFA
and enter into new contracts to find
um Partners in the community that that
would provide peer-to-peer grief support
uh to Children who's suffering from the
no I no
representative you were in order on
questions do you have a question
you don't have to have a question
I guess perhaps the question should have
gone to
um Ms Fox last week on uh what could
have necessitated this or how many
children it would apply to and if we
have other programs already
um that are working that address similar
issues but all of those I think are just
going to hang out there
representative hole do you have a
question I do thank you
uh Mr White I remember a number of
programs was this one of the ones where
she mentioned that it was not as
important as others at one point Miss
Fox mentioned that one program she was
willing to let go I don't remember if it
was this one or not
sure so that we have a we have a couple
of prioritized needs in the dbh realm
um there isn't there was a new
prioritized need it's three and a half
million in the first year and 1.5
million in the second year if I'm
remembering this correctly uh for the
community mental health program support
that that that was that was her priority
um I I don't I I don't know if she
necessarily used the language less
important but
that that other item that's included on
this division three status of action
sheet that that was a priority for her
okay thank you
representative just as a reminder I'm
pretty sure she stated and I believe Mr
White did as well this is one of those
things that was added by the governor
not not by DHHS in the hb2 process
all right so
so if we were to delete it and if the
department believed strongly enough that
this should not be deleted then they
still have another bite at the Apple
with the Senate I think so I I I I I I
know that we're going to need money
because we are short
um and I'll tell you why I think we're
short because I had dinner with uh
Senator Lang on Friday who's over on
Senate Ways and Means and you know I
heard last week in a different meeting
that we have sort of become accustomed
to the Senate finding more money than
the house has and and there was in this
other meeting Clarity that that was
probably going to happen this year that
we were not going to have the the Senate
Santa come in and and and bring all of
us more money that's typically been
what's happening so independently over
dinner
Senator Lang told me that he thinks our
house Ways and Means approach
was
more about the negotiation and
compromise between competing points of
view and that and that it was
interesting the associations where it
was a Republican and Democrat viewing
things one way and a Democrat and
Republican viewing in different ways and
that and then it was a very much an
accommodation process which which isn't
abnormal for ways and means but his
observation was he thought we came to
the wrong conclusion many times and that
he went back through
meals and rooms taxes to just sort of do
a sanity check and based on the
statistics that he was provided
we have been housing using our money a
tremendous number of homeless people
using federal funds and every time we
pay for a hotel or motel the state is
getting an eight and a half percent cut
of that from the m r tax and so he's
saying if you just looked at that one
factor and you eliminated the federal
money going to that particular program
the reduction in the m r tax on that was
something like 80 million dollars a year
that he doesn't think the house weighs
and means did now
I'm not at all suggesting that we change
what we're supposed to do what we're
supposed to do is we're supposed to stay
inside hb17 the ways and means estimate
but I'm just letting you know or
thinking about having you think about
the possibility of what happens if the
Senate comes back and says there's
actually less money significantly less
money so I I you know I I just think for
the purposes of worst case scenario
planning we ought to be thinking in that
way and so for that very long reason if
we can delete a tiny thing like 1.5
million on Section 49 and 50 knowing
that the Senate can come back and add it
back if it's Justified and that there's
money available I'm I'm okay with that
um is there any more discussion or did I
suck all the air out of this one uh
representative hole you did not suck all
the air out of this room
given
some of the serious unmet needs
currently in the mental health area
right the hospital the the lawsuit that
we're facing in other things and knowing
that we're already under water
financially I think we're going to have
to look everywhere we can for a million
okay so is there more discussion
representative Mooney is uh is looking
for representative Weiler
um but
um
do you all have a reaction
to the proposal to delete this thinking
the Senate can add it back is that
well
doing things here and hoping that the
Senate will
undo them and do something different
it's not I for me it's not not something
I
I try not to I try not to do that I try
not to think my in my own head about
doing it that way
um though in years past that's that has
happened the center often has better
Revenue estimates than we do
um but that wouldn't be the reason I
would vote to take to put it in or take
how do you think you would vote
if I vote to leave it in at this point
okay
all right uh so we are looking for
representative Weiler who's not checked
in yet so um so we're going to come back
to I'm sorry we're going to come back to
this issue because we're not ready for a
straw vote
do you have another Point you're trying
to make or on this point well you had a
rep representative Mr Ripple pass out
your other Amendment which I think we
could consider now couldn't we right I
just trying to close one thing at a time
this one I'm going to park until we get
representative Weiler
uh now I think the amendment that you
handed out is on 226
um this this looks probably more than it
really is when you when you describe
what it's doing this is uh related to
the current statute on the workplace
violence prevention program that was
advocated by both the hospital
Association and the nursing association
Nurses Association and and maybe another
Association but those were the two two
big ones
so so that bill that we saw last term
did not have a fiscal note attached to
it
and that was probably something that
that this division could have caught and
said hey there should be because we were
putting Manpower obligations on the
department for which we didn't put any
sort of money on there and then this
program was in effect during the entire
Governor's budget cycle and for some
reason I'm not looking for the reason
why but for some reason the department
didn't incorporate this program in their
budget and so it's not in the budget and
so they've asked us with 226 the way
it's written now
to basically just I think the shorthand
is uh I gotta find my document but
basically to just suspend this program
because the department doesn't have the
Manpower now to do it that's that's my
thumbnail is that close
yes okay so
so I didn't want to do that
because because I know how important
this is to the hospitals and the nursing
nurse Professionals in the state and I
think it's important to all of us to
make sure that our health care providers
can work in an environment which they're
reasonably assured of their personal
safety and the safety of their patients
and peers so so I I do like the idea of
this program where the concept is to
have all of the private sector
hospitals and I think it was like it
turned out to be about three of the
largest clinics participate in this
commission so that they can bring
forward particular incidents discuss the
incidents and maintain some sort of
Records so that they can do some Trend
analysis to figure out what kinds of
incidences are happening and and
therefore with looking at that Trend
analysis see if there's maybe
legislative Solutions or other workplace
policy sees that could be implemented
without the state that's for them to be
able to find out how they how we could
best mitigate the risks
the challenge I think to the to the
private sector is when they bring in
that kind of data they don't they they
want to be able to discuss it in a way
in which that communication is
privileged and not subject to Discovery
should there be a lawsuit and so so the
biggest thing in the statute as
constructed is is basically you know the
bubble wrap to let the commission have
those discussions in a way in which it's
privileged and confidential and I think
that's necessary for them to have the
level of Engagement necessary because
they'll be dealing with a lot of
personal information maybe some Phi but
mostly just personal information that
should be protected and but but still it
might be discoverable if somebody wants
to sue so I I I kind of agree with that
but the current law says they must go
through the department must lead an
initiative of to go through the gel car
process to create all of the regulations
to create the the the rules for this
privileged and confidential
Communications
the department has come back and said
hey we just don't have the manpower to
do this
so
I don't want the the lack of resources
on the part of the state to prevent the
private sector from confidently moving
forward with this program because as I
understand it they really haven't stood
it up yet what what I would like to do
is to create an environment in which the
private sector can come together and
begin to work on sort of the workflow
processes and the kind of decisions they
would make so that when it is time to
start figuring out how what how we would
protect this data we know what the what
the workflows are and what kind of data
we're dealing with and it just it sets
it up so that we can deal with the the
confidentiality part of it
I want to consult with a lawyer because
I think we can provide as legislature
privilege and confidential
Communications capability without the
state being involved and without going
through jailcar but I want to talk to a
lawyer to verify that
and I haven't so
um so what so what does all what do all
these words do basically it says look
the state is not ready to be a full
partner in this program
so we're not obligating the state to do
anything but we're not telling them they
can't either so the department and the
AG and labor under this amendment can
still if as time is available go ahead
and participate in this program to the
extent that they can and they can do
anything that that statute says they're
supposed to do like data basing and
putting on websites and they can do all
of that if they have resources available
but they're not obligated to do it it
would still let the
commission form get organized start to
identify their their work practices and
and maybe you know do some do some real
work too without having to come across
the confidential
information so
so this amendment does that it says you
know go ahead dear private sector it's a
good program go do it the state can't
participate this budget cycle on an
obligated or mandatory basis
maybe we have some resource availability
later
will participate to the extent that we
have that Manpower but but until then
don't wait for us go
and and so
um so that's what this amendment tries
to do representative erf
which I've been describe in detail what
um
Mr Ripple do you want to walk us through
the amendment are you in a position to
do that do you do that better than I do
sure so there are a few instances in
which agency participation
was suspended for the biennium in the
previous Amendment and is still
suspended in this amendment and those
are ons line those are on lines eight
through
15 of page one
but there were a few instances in which
suspension for the biennium race some
problems as you mentioned uh the rule
making ability
rather than suspending the Department's
ability to adopt rules this keeps that
ability in statute but changes it from
Shell to May and that's on page one line
and again on page two
line nine
also starting on page one line 31 this
allows the commission to request that
the Department of Health and Human
Services assumes certain functions so
rather than suspending that for the
biennium rule that allows the commission
to make a request which the department
can then either
you have further questions are there any
questions just related to the details of
the amendment
represent a Stringham yeah I'm just I'm
just wondering if the movement from uh
kind of a more positive affirmative you
must do this or shall to May uh really
deep burdens burdens us from any
Financial commitment to supporting to
supporting this process or not so
if I heard you right I think you're in
agreement with the intent of the of of
of the amendment which is to permit
state support state investments in this
program to the extent that they are
available without obligating or
mandating it it's it's essentially at
the Strategic level changing a shall
the state shall do these things to
basically May and while still
encouraging them to do it if they can
that that's the intent okay I I thought
that I thought that's what it was and it
still involves the Health and Human
Services oversight committee as well as
the commission at least reading a memo I
guess that comes in or a report from
each of these member organizations
so is that something that can be done
without any funding I I believe so I I
think the private sector can go forward
and they can do their reporting and I
believe that HHS is duly constituted in
the oversight area to hear those reports
because
um one of the functions of that
communication is if there are
legislative changes that may need to
take effect the oversight is a good
portal for doing that I I do think it's
it's having worked in hospitals in other
settings it may also be the case that
that they may find trends that they can
deal with their own policies without it
being a law so so there's an opportunity
to to find some good ideas and Implement
them while the you know the state tries
to get in a position to to be more
supportive
very vague and it's really unclear
how this information is going to be
collected and what kind of consistency
there's going to be I would think we
would want
we would want the state to be involved
in
this
project I just it feels like taking the
state out of it or just leaving it out
there as they may if they want to
um
really
really is not not a good choice for us
it
to make I think it really I think it
really does need the state involvement
as as well as the private it's a good
place for there to be a partnership on
working on this
so would you believe I don't disagree
with any of that I'm just dealing with
the reality that the department came to
us and said they don't have the Manpower
resources to do it their recommendation
was we suspend the whole thing
so while this appears vague I think it's
actually pretty precise in terms of
cross walking back into the the each
element of the statute
and basically supporting the program to
the extent that the state can without
shutting it down a suspension would be
horrible if we did with the Department
is asking and we suspended the statute
for two years that would essentially be
sending up an Amber if not a red light
for them to just go start taking care of
business and and I try to say this but
maybe I didn't say it very well is is I
think that they have a lot of spade work
to do some groundwork to do on just
identifying what types what categories
of of information that they would want
to receive what kind of communication
channels they would use what kind of
decision processes they would use
without actually handling live data
basically setting up this system
so that they already once we can per MIT
or or
secure their their privacy interests in
that data so I just think they have a
lot of work that they can do and I don't
want to slow them down
so so to follow up on this Mr White
is it the Department's position
that you would still like to just
so I I think it's important to remember
that when we were preparing our agency
budget at that point in time the
economic Outlook was was pretty bad
um and and the guidance that we did
receive was three percent increase in 24
and zero percent increase in 25 and we
had what I would consider to be Baseline
operating costs included in our
prioritized needs listing so at that
point in time when the department was
looking at what is new what is existing
what do we absolutely need to have
funded in our operating budget you know
when I look at like mmis that was in hb2
that was a prioritized need we
absolutely need that and I think this
committee under certainly understands
that and is recognized and I appreciate
that but that was kind of the
environment when we put together our
original agency budget requests that we
were working within things have
obviously changed since then our initial
recommendation was to suspend that
without additional resources
um if if additional resources were
provided we would certainly move move
forward with that
so I have to summarize I was looking for
yes or no and what I think I heard you
say is yes it's still your
recommendation unless we can provide
additional resources correct okay I I
like those short clear things my little
head can wrap around representative
so I want to say number one I approve of
this amendment and this is the way to go
I did speak with the representative of
the Nurses Association and they totally
are on board with this in fact they
helped us to uh to draft it
um while maybe the state's more active
involvement would be better it's really
what they want is just so they can get
together under cover of the state which
this gives them to get these issues to
raise these issues to get them on the
table and quite honestly they expected
to be doing the quote databasing the
whole thing with the website that was
not even in the original proposal we
looked at two years ago that was
something that the legislature added
um to you know kind of whatever
um so I do think that this is viable and
better than suspending it totally for
sure
Mr White could you just tell us briefly
what kinds of resources you need I don't
think I've seen that
sure
um to do this we we would need at at
least at least one position a program
specialist uh that would be a labor
grade 25 the approximately 85 000 in
fiscal year 24 but that assumes that
we're budgeting out of step one and then
90 000 and say fiscally or 25 rarely do
we
hire at step one in order to get the
experience necessary to complete that
um Melissa says here she can also speak
to some of the the knowledge gaps that
our department has around this type of
work that that we wouldn't need to
hi good morning Melissa sains here I'm
the chief legal officer for the
Department of Health and Human Services
and part of my purview is the Bureau of
Licensing and certification which does
health facilities and child care
licensing
um I have briefly been able to read the
amendment so I don't know if your
question relates to the original or if
you're asking about the amendment do you
want to clarify was that your question
my question was around what kind of
resources you would need to do this work
to do this work under the amendment or
or originally existing stature existing
the existing statute yeah so so Nathan
was correct we would need a program
specialist to manage the program manage
the you know the tasks the
administrative tasks around the
commission as well as the rules and and
other things and then we have also a
database in there in the statute as it
is now that would need to be created and
then analyzed and Reporting done on it
and all of those type of things so that
would need a staff member as for the
tasks that the um
that the Bureau of Licensing and
certification would have to do those
those folks are Health Facilities
licensing which has to do with health
and safety of the residents so they
don't have the expertise or experience
around kind of the workplace safety
piece although there's training and
other things that um they that could get
them up to speed typically the um you
know OSHA compliance and compliance with
workplace safety is not done through the
Bureau of Licensing and certification
because it's only focused on health and
safety of the residents and so um so
they would need some some training and
other things to to be able to accomplish
these tasks and oversee this program
so I think I just heard you say startup
costs of about two hundred thousand
dollars with at least one FTE associated
with that and some money to help with
the I.T part of it and maybe ongoing
expenses and uh you know the the 80 to
100 000 range because after the
program's implemented then it you'd need
less Manpower that that sounds about
right yes thank you
any other questions representative
Morgan
well I I guess I'm concerned because I I
just don't see this as a full-time
person
I guess defining the work you think
this person would need to do and how you
think the commission would operate to
clarify that so sure thank you for the
question so um I think that part of the
so it's kind of three different tasks
that we see first is is the training and
knowledge necessary to not only kind of
bring the program into the department
but then train the staff that's
necessary to oversee it um if it is the
Bureau of Licensing and certification
staff or or other staff that may be
involved in in this so there's the kind
of training component that they'd be
responsible for they'd also be
responsible for the database so not just
development of the database but
maintaining it receiving reports and and
analyzing those reports and Reporting
out based off of what was required in
the statute and then the other part is
the administration of the commission to
ensure that the commission is meeting
that there's meeting minutes there's a
there's a place for them to have those
that they um that the administrative
rules are are created up to date and and
then all basically all things around
that so I would see that as three
different tasks that they'd be
all right are there go ahead represent
trollerski thank you
um my concern is
this ties the hands of the state moving
forward or perhaps gives the state an
out to not participate in the future I
understand the suspension
just puts the brakes on and then in two
years the state is required to move
forward with it again and I'm afraid
that amending the program at this point
would remove that obligation can you
please speak to the views of the
department on on that I mean I sort of
feel like I'm hearing a desire that I
understand you don't have the resources
but is the desire there to join the
program if we were in a Rosy world with
money falling out of the sky yeah that
would be great I think the program is
really important I think that it's a
great program I think the department
supports the program it's just that we
we need the approve we need an
appropriation we need the resource to be
able to to you know help with the
program do you see a problem with the
state not participating in the first two
years of the program and would the
department
pursue
trying to get the funding and then join
the program yes that's that's I I
foresee that the department will
continue to try to get the funding
appropriate so that we have the
so so I had asked Mr Ripple to be very
careful as this language was being
crafted to make sure that any suspension
of the current statute was just a
temporary to get us through this
biennium with the idea that Mr White in
the department can will have it in
statute and will include it in the next
budget cycle so so I think Mr Ripple was
just about to respond to what I just
said or not now do you have a question I
do are you saying that in the amendment
it it specifies that this is just for
this biennium does it revert back to the
original statute after the conclusion of
the two years uh I'd say it differently
but end up at the same place the statute
is not changed this is a temporary
suspension of the obligations the state
has for this budget cycle while
simultaneously allowing for the state if
they find additional resources to invest
them without having to come back to
fiscal or anyone so may I ask
after the conclusion of 2025 will the
state then revert to Shell adopting
instead of the may may oh I'll let
represent or Mr Ripple answer that I
believe the answer is yes but
as written those those would not revert
that the temporary suspensions began on
line eight and end on line 15 but the
other changes would be permanent shout
out to May and
the request of the department rather
than delegating to the department would
be permanent so can I clear can I just
ask for a clarification so in at the
conclusion of 2025 the state would not
be obligated
to then address this issue again they
would still have the option to not
participate
well I think in the case of rule making
and supporting the
commission at the commission's request
that's true the other responsibilities
would be would
go back into effect like on line 10
maintaining a website database design
and implementation that would once again
further questions I I I sense that there
uh
am I reading body language and questions
properly
I like the opportunity Community for the
Democrats to talk about it all right
that's fair we'll we'll put this one on
hold
um
at some point we're going to have to
force votes because we're
time is gone
maybe we can do that when representative
Wilder gets here that would be great so
so I can see because of his wisdom I
think
okay so
um welcome I think the root the main
reason you came over was to talk to us
about the use of the word immediate
um I and I'm not sure where we're at but
I know we need to talk about how to
Mr Ripple which one of these is is that
related to
okay so this was this was grayed out oh
this was about the whether or not the
word immediate was necessary to qualify
whether or not the transport of somebody
needing transport had to be immediate or
not immediate so what what can you tell
us
um so this section was part of the
governor's budget this was this was the
governor's office language so I can tell
you what um what we see at the
department uh when it comes to this
section immediately does cause some
confusion
um a lot of people don't understand kind
of what do they mean by immediately is
it immediately after the person has
stabilized is it immediately after
somebody is
um you know ready for transport because
sometimes you can you can schedule
somebody for discharge at a hospital but
they don't transport for hours later and
is that immediate when is when does
immediate kind of happen and I think
even in the courts there was there's
been a lot of kind of back and forth in
some of our litigation matters
um so so that was understandably the
reason there was just some confusion
around the language and so this would
make it clearer by removing okay so
there would be two ways to make it clear
the governor's uh office's approach was
to remove the word immediate the the
other approach I think it sounds like
would be to better Define and and
provide some scope around the definition
of the word immediate how we want to
interpret it it would would that have
been an alternative way so we have
rulemaking uh rulemaking Authority for
this program for rsa135c we have very
broad rule making Authority so what we
typically do is we bring the parties
together and come up with a decision
through rulemaking so that would
actually clarify things and I don't know
so I don't know if it necessarily needs
an amendment in the statute other than
the removal of the word I think it's it
would be done through rulemaking through
stakeholder engagement to to kind of
determine what that transition would
look like so so the feedback I'm I'm
picking up is that there's Community
concern uh about the idea that if we
remove the word immediate it will signal
to everyone involved in the delivery
system the transport system
a lack of urgency that a sort of a
lackadaisical approach to Patient
transport will evolve into the culture
around patient evacuation
can you can you address that concern do
you do you what do you think about the
validity of those concerns that the
system will become lackadaisical if we
remove the word immediate
From dhhs's perspective that is not what
would result just removing the word
immediately it's to to help with the
confusion around it and what that means
and what that means for providers what
that means for the Community Mental
Health Centers and kind of working with
them towards a solution so that's not
what DHHS would ever do or expect to do
to just you know not have a sense of
urgency for these individuals
are there questions representative
Stringham this is sort of an area you've
shown interest in no on on this
provision I mean I I don't think this
provision belongs in the budget bill
so okay so so you're in favor of what
leaving it alone and just deleting the
section
I would personally delete it
I don't I don't think this is the place
for
for us to be uh making that decision so
you're saying it's a policy issue and we
should leave it to the policy committee
I think you know there are decisions
like this that um I think we need to
give it more thought and
I think at this point I I mean I I would
not vote to do this at this point
representative
so I would just ask I get you could do
it in rule making but could you give us
language that we could put into the
statute right now
um that would be sort of minimally
acceptable to you for the executive
branch who's DHHS so I think you know we
address some of this right now in rule
making and it's a little bit broader
than what I would suggest for a statute
revision the the sections I mean we talk
a lot about those who have
um you know some type of medical issue
other than mental health uh you know
they come to they come to the hospital
with uh on on some kind of drug or
alcohol and so they're intoxicated or or
they have a acquired brain disorder
which isn't necessarily a mental illness
or they have some other type of dementia
some other type of medical concern and
so some of these things need to be
fleshed out prior to the transfer prior
to the certificate being complete
um so we address all of these kind of
different instances in the statute I
mean in the rule excuse me so you know I
wouldn't want to kind of suggest that we
put all of that in the statute I think
it's just Clarity around when is the
certificate completed what information
is necessary for it to be completed so
that they would then be transferred so
it's the the qualification all the
qualifications around it prior to
transfer and ensuring that that is laid
out properly
okay I get you don't want to put all the
details in but if these are already in
rules
and you all only all you do is make
reference to them then is there some way
with high-level language making
reference to rules that you could
address the concern which is I think
legitimate that the folks on the outside
looking in saying well you take out
immediately and all of a sudden they're
just going to continue to sit there in
the ER until whenever yeah I'd have to I
have to think about it I don't know if I
have an answer for you right now we'd
have to put a little bit of thought on
into what language would would work to
address both of those concerns
I just think that's the only hope in
terms of keeping this result or keeping
this in there at all yeah and I can also
um touch base with the governor's office
since this was their language and see if
there's something else that they might
suggest
thank you so not seeing any more
questions at this point I I think I
would suggest uh we hold this and and
let the respective groups caucus around
it and if you could come back with some
more language what kind of timeline do
you think you're on to to answer the
mail so I'll I'll talk to the governor's
office today and see if there's
something and then I'll talk with the
with the team back who does this work at
the department and see if there's
something that we can come up with all
okay so I would like to come back
um over the of the three things on this
sheet that we've talked about two of
them were gray one of them was still in
White on hold so we've got those that
we're going to hold off on a straw vote
on those but before going and hitting
the next uh hold area which is 232
I want to provide a last call
Opportunity if there's any of these
items in gray that we kind of
tentatively agreed to how we would
handle them Friday we we let we reserved
the right to come back and revisit any
or all of them or is there any on here
that you care to revisit representative
tolerski
thank you last week
voted against
removing the Choose Love program I
believe
um representative Stringham and I were
the two that voted no so after hearing
what we heard this morning I would be
open to revisiting that one so section
212 page 26. 212.
so 212 when we ended it last week we
voted to to delete it and you would like
to revisit that
the non-pravailing side I would like to
encourage everyone to vote having been
alive and present in the moment okay I
hear you okay
um representative hole thank you Mr
chair
um I'm section 223 relative to the
budget for the sununa Youth Services
Center I'm okay deleting it and moving
to hb1 so that Amendment I'm okay with I
think we should revisit now that we have
an updated budget the portion that goes
so so no change from what we said Friday
no change to hb2 correct
no change to what to hb2 removing the
note to remove it is fine right the
amendment 0972h
um however when we get to hb1 I would
like to revisit it oh I understand what
you're saying okay all right very good
uh any other representative Waller I
think you had your hand up do you still
have any of these gray areas that you'd
like to pull to have us rediscuss no I
wanted to do um Choose Love also yeah
yeah okay very good I don't know if
those rules really matter as much we're
just you know but but okay may I ask a
question yes you may
um what we just discussed the workplace
violence prevention program um section
226 there's an amendment number here is
that an old Amendment we're no longer
considering
that's probably true I think we've done
some iterations and some work and some
more coordination
um and so the one that is viable is uh
1086 dated March 19. the other ones are
representative hole
section 230 which was relative
to moving over the unclassified
positions within legal to
sorry the classified positions to
unclassified I would like to discuss
with this after we've had a caucus
okay so there were two dealing with
Personnel movements there were 229 and
230 is your question on both or just
230.
any other gray areas to be brought back
all right not seeing any let's go to
let's do a time check we've got we've
got 30 minutes
there's a been a caucus request to start
at noon that will will honor then we've
got the full finance committee meeting
at one we have a lot of voting to do
that could take a long time
my intent is to
put this work session into recess when
we stop and when the full finance
committee completes it work it's work I
want to come back and keep slogging
through this just because we're we're
out of days not out of hours but we're
out of days so
um I did ask you to bring your sleeping
bags so
all right
two three two
Kerry Ford of funds in the developmental
Services acquired
okay I have to I have to find my sheet
alternatively representative Earth well
while I'm looking through my papers if
you want to go ahead and get this
conversation on 232 started I'm fine
with that
are you ready
I guess the first thing I asked you Mr
do you have the I don't actually have
I might suggest holding on this one for
now because I do have amendments for you
uh that relate to this section uh but I
would like to show them for you to you
first okay um so I I would leave this
one on hold what are you thinking of
um
okay like is it safe for me to talk
about what I'm thinking about going with
this absolutely okay
so
the this section of
the budget
has a law that applies to it and I'm
sure Mr White will correct me if I'm
wrong here
that states that the budgeting for it
must look who's here must be done
must be done based on the
need and as I understand it that is
something that's determined separately
from the ability to deliver the services
so in other words it must be by law
knowingly over budgeted even though they
know those Services can never be
highly unlikely to be delivered and
there is a there's a calculation for
that and and
um that obviously it's sensitive and
here I am I camera talking about it
um that uh lets us well no not lets us
so they could budget for it better is
the bottom line
so that the services that could be
delivered could be budgeted and the
reason I bring this up even though it is
a very very sensitive subject is we are
in a very
tight situation here specifically with
regard to I think all of our desires to
address Medicaid rates
beyond the 3.1 percent and we've gotten
some uh benefit there in terms of the
hospital saying that they're willing to
forego there whatever their piece is 10
billion or so and we've picked up pieces
here and there but essentially what this
says is this law essentially what the
effect is is leave money sitting in the
bank at the end of this biennium whereas
we could address it we could use that
money during this biennium to for
instance addressing the Medicaid rates
like the nursing home rates and and so
on and so forth so that is the intent
behind
um considering this amendment which
we'll have I guess later today or
tomorrow
um to basically make more funds
available for us to use in looking at
the Medicaid rate increases that we've
been talking about at length if there's
any questions that I well I wasn't clear
all right uh you you you did well I just
found my sheet of paper
so so when we left this my note said
that we were leaning towards deletion or
at least that was my question but the
amendment will change that conversation
and go to 233 which is I think up your
alley are you ready or should we wait
until we know more about the the money
obligations I'm I'm ready if you'd like
to talk about that go ahead so this one
I believe Mr Ripple does have or we
already have it or I handed that one out
yesterday I think so so you can you all
find that
foreign
there are two pieces to it
I can speak to without it but probably
should find it I can print out a few
since I'm no doubt the person that's
worst with paper if you could print at
okay so I can kind of describe it now
that I have in front of me the hb2 piece
is number zero eight seven oh it's a
short Amendment looks kind of like this
uh handily has my name near the top
underneath hb1 Amendment
and the department is DHHS waiver
nursing home payments facility payments
blah blah blah and it looks kind of like
this
yeah yeah
I know
look they don't all have my name
hopefully
and I can speak to it whether you have
it or not it's pretty straightforward
okay
so the HB 2 piece is very simple
last
biennium we changed the law
to only allow for a two percent increase
per year in the county cap so that's the
law as it stands now
the
uh hp2 piece doesn't does not change the
law
it only states that we're going to
freeze the county cap at the current FY
23 level for the next two years
so it doesn't change the law after the
this biennium the two percent thing
would happen with respect to the level
that we set it at now so this freezes it
and the the amendment actually States
the level 131 million 849 659 would
become the county cap for the year now
there's two unfortunately two pieces to
the impact this has on the budget one of
which is related to that Amendment one
of which is not related to that
Amendment
when the governor's budget was put
together there was some error in the in
the HP one piece I believe is where it
fell with regard to applying that two
percent
rule if you will that should have been
applied in other words it should have
been very simple this time due to the
budget from the executive branch side
the the most they should have put in
there was a two percent increase for
each of these coming two years they for
whatever reason the number was much
greater than that and the net effect of
that is a cost to us if you will in the
budget in other words we have to find
this 10 million dollars pretty much
regardless because this is the law of 10
million and and this is shown by the way
on that the the hb1 sheet that I was
speaking to in that top um section
beside description uh number one where
it refers to 10 million 10 million 516
357 000 300 516 000 357 is needed to
align HP one to hb2 so that's 10 million
dollars it has to be found in our budget
in the house budget
just to basically apply with uh to uh
comply with laws that exists and then we
talk about the amendment hb2 which is
eliminating that
raising it up to a percent part of it
and that's number two which costs if you
will another 7.9 roughly a million
dollars over the biennium and down below
um I'll try to explain this but Mr
Ribble may need to may need to help me
correct myself here
um it's basically the private local
funds uh the source of funds 005
and if you add up 2024 uh negative 5.3
million the change under under change
and then 20 25 under change negative
13.7 million if you add those two
numbers together I believe you should
get the same
result as if you add the 10 up under
description the 10.5 together with the
7.9 is that correct Mr Ripple it is so
that's the sum
Mr chair Mr representative thank you so
if I'm reading
correctly the sheet regarding hb2 right
the math error started out at 18.48
million dollars and if we don't do this
we have the 18.48 million plus
some additional money to bring us up to
the two percent no no no
so to correct for the
for the law being improperly applied
that's the 10.5 million okay
and and by the way the reason I guess I
should have gone further with this the
whole point of working on this area is
that this obviously directly impacts all
of our County nursing homes and uh
cutting nursing homes are funded by our
local property taxes so this helps to uh
control a property our local property
taxes that's really what's behind us
so in other words if you're in favor of
the earth proposal you can tell your
constituents that you have done
something actual to reduce their
property taxes
in case you ever want to say that
go ahead I just have a question for
representative
um
we're freezing it at the last biennium's
level next go-round do we is the two
percent on that Frozen level or
is is the amount still increasing
somewhere does that make sense yeah I
think we're just saying is does it
continue to compound through this and
then I I would assume and and I'm sure
the attorneys if they're slowly present
but Mr Ripple corresponded to this as
well I believe the way the law specifies
its two percent increase over whatever
the current then current uh rate is uh
so that the cat I shouldn't say rate cap
so I believe what will happen is at the
end of the beginning of the next
biennium if the budget is properly
calculated they would they would add 2.2
excuse me two percent to the 131 million
849 659 that we're freezing it at to get
the FY 20 what's the next year six and
then they'd add the two percent to that
to get the FY 20
seven
and if I'm wrong Mr Ripple I'll let you
correct me
I believe that's correct I'm just
pulling up the statute now to see how it
reads
just one moment my concern is just if
we're digging a deeper deeper hole that
we're gonna have to eventually fill
when you say digging a deeper hole or
not the not the other way building a
bigger Hill that we have to climb
um I I don't see it that way okay
um and and here's why
so
this whole County cap thing this whole
approach of
the counties paying for nursing care
arose from a deal that was made long
before I got here
um but definitely doing Mary Jane's
tenure
um having to do with how the counties
and the state should divvy things up my
putting that aside and it's not a deal
like hard in paper or some kind of deal
that anybody's locked into anything it
was just sort of a gentleman's agreement
I guess but the way I look at this is
nursing homes
are the state drives their costs because
the state sets their rates
property taxes for the most part and I
would say almost
100 other than this are related to
things that we in our towns vote for our
town budgets our school budgets our fire
police and so on and so forth they don't
we don't as as townspeople vote for
anything to do with the nursing home
costs
and as I said those costs are driven by
the state so quite honestly I think the
state should be picking up more of that
because they're dropping the costs uh
and and they should be you know assuming
this costs but that's just my philosophy
so I don't view it as a whole that's
being um that's that's growing if you
will I I view it is basically holding at
the constant relatively constant level
the commitment that the counties have
the County nursing homes have to
contribute to the Medicaid costs of
their elderly
so as I recall last budget cycle
represented nordgren and representative
Wallner that this County cap issue we
ended up unanimously agreeing on then
and that what we're trying to do now is
to continue that same level of
commitment that we made two years ago is
that is that a fair summary
yes I think that's fair all right
um
you know I feel I will feel comfortable
with this
if I'm sure that
um in the future it's not that we're
going to have to make up the two percent
that we didn't add this year I mean that
I just want to be sure yeah that's right
I just want to be sure that we aren't
hit
next time with a four percent
um and that's the only that's the only
question I have I love the idea of
freezing it
so here's how statute currently reads it
says the cap and total Billings shall
not exceed an amount an annual increase
of two percent in any year of the
biennium uh again I'm I'm not a lawyer
but I would interpret this to mean there
can be no no more than a two percent
increase from the prior year
yeah
okay so I'm I'm feeling like we could do
a straw vote on this is there any
opposition to the Earth item dealing
with County cap I'm not seeing any okay
if you are in favor of accepting the
Earth amendments to hb1 and hb2 related
so that's good
yes yes go ahead
thank you Mr Ripple what was the exact
RSA on that if you could
it's RSA 167 colon 18a
Roman 2.
so let's come back to 232
um
we have
how rigid is your 12 o'clock time is it
like really hard or soft
hard okay so I don't want to do 232 now
then because I I think that could take a
while
um I would like to see if we can knock
yeah that's why we're pushing towards
trying to get this done can we go down
to 254 did we ever get a definition a
written definition on Family Resource
Center we did and I we somebody read it
to me that was you
um
okay so Mr Ripple where were we on 254
I'm not sure I don't think there was a
consensus at the time that you were
because my note says that we were okay
or maybe that was just me thinking I was
okay we definitely had a disagreement I
believe we should delete it but there
are others here who thought that um we
shouldn't
okay so representative verf is
suggesting that we delete 254
where is the opposition to that
representative norgren I'm not opposed
to that I'm just I have a note beside it
that says it was covered money
originally that it was covered money yes
and now they're looking for General
funds is that your interpretation okay
representative Wallner
well I'm going to vote no
on deleting it because I think these
programs are really really valuable in
the communities they're providing a lot
of services to families families feel
comfortable going to these Family
Resource Centers and I I feel you know
for our
Child Abuse Prevention
helping families find resources I I
think these are really important
programs so I'm going to vote no so so
Ms Hebert welcome back
can you just give us 30 seconds
time yourself in your head 30 seconds on
what sort of metrics we have to know
whether or not this program is effective
or whatever else you want to say but I I
am interested in metrics when we have
them yeah for the record Karen Hebert
director for the division of economic
stability for DHHS I think one of the
best metrics we have for this program
relates to the prevention policies of
Family Resource Centers which measure
the recidivism if you will of the number
of children who may return into dcyf
services
the rate right now of that return after
receiving services
is less than three percent
which is a pretty good metric so that is
that is one of the key effects so three
percent sounds great what would it what
would it be you think do we have any
historical record on what it was before
this program I mean you know I wouldn't
think so that's why we do programs so we
can measure them
um all right so uh representative
I would just like to point out unless
I'm mistaken this isn't deleting the
program this program is if again if I'm
correct
on the wrong page
thank you
right and I believe it's on page nine
eleven of HP one
if I'm not mistaken in 72 16 called the
kinship Grant which does have funds in
there not anywhere near this much
Mr White has a comment sure just a
couple of points of clarification so SB
444 from the 2022 legislative session
appropriated one million dollars for the
first time towards Family Resource
Centers
um the the confusion around the arpa
dollars um there was a provision
included in that that allowed us to
request arpa dollars and if it was to
determined that they were available they
could be used it was determined by
gopher that they were not available the
department used General funds the reason
you see a million dollar appropriate or
request
um here we put those forward as
prioritized needs was to can was to
continue funding the program at the same
level that the legislature had funded in
okay
any other further comment
um
representative ver if you still suggests
deleting the item while leaving the
program well going back to
uh what was what representative Wallner
said um I totally agree with her
regarding Effectiveness and again I'm
looking at the need for Medicare rates
I'm also reminding myself that this was
a senate program and I know we mentioned
this earlier I don't want to think about
what the Senate is going to do but
um
I'd like to see them
think about how they want to deal with
the balance between this and the
Medicaid rates my
choice would be to focus on the Medicaid
so
so yes I would still want to delete it
yeah so I'm I'm actually very
predisposed to finding whatever money we
can to put into the Medicaid targeted
rate
program that we're going to talk about
later today that's why Mr lippman I
imagine you're here I'm so sorry you can
enjoy a nice lunch in our cafeteria but
but then we're going to come back we're
going to do the full Finance thing and
we're going to be recessed in division
three so we may not be back to talk
about Medicaid in more detail until I
don't know four I hate to say five
o'clock I don't know how long the
finance committee is going to take but
um go ahead I just have an inkling it
shouldn't be too bad from things I heard
this morning but I can't lock Us in okay
keep hope alive
all right so I think we probably should
defer a vote on 254 is my sense
uh we have five minutes before I think
we're not going to do 257 quick
we
234 can we do let's touch on 234 for for
five minutes or less choices for
I have I have no personal notes on this
except I love this program I have a
question go ahead representative so uh
this section I think
um uh is is wholly meant to cover
increased utilization for choices for
independent Services is that right or
does it also address rate Inc rate
increases
so this covers existing service levels
and additional projected service levels
with with no change in rates correct
that's an excellent qualification this
is changing volume not price
Waller representative Waller so
I'm sorry could could you just
clarify that for me again
it's addressing existing caseload
did we not have enough in the budget to
cover the caseload that we have now sure
so so this kind of goes back to what
you've you've already heard me say a
number of times where when we were
trying to get our efficiency expenditure
budget within the three percent there
were certain things that didn't make it
within that a portion of this was for
funding service levels at the existing
level and then some money
um as well for for what we expect to see
yeah
and I think I asked this before but
did Relapse funds in this in choices for
Independence
uh I I don't know off the top of my head
I I can I can look that up
and if we did it was obviously because
we couldn't find the providers right
because the demand is out there right
so representative or go ahead Miss rebel
I think if I recall correctly that in
the CFI lines uh no money was allowed to
lapse it was to be distributed to
Providers at the end of the biennium
yes so if there was a Labs it's going to
carry over into the next fiscal year is
that the takeaway it would be paid out
to Providers instead oh that's right
this is the bonus checks for not doing
anything
that's the way it feels to me but go
ahead represent I'd rather have that
money go into rates so they can hire the
people to provide the services and not
have to pay end of the two-year
payouts to keep them viable
which is what it is go ahead represent a
walner well I would like to know what
that how much was paid out in that way
because that would if they hadn't had
that into but if we didn't have that
phrase in the budget then we would have
lapsed that money so I would like to
know how much we paid out
at that point
sure and and and uh this this is
accounting unit 2152 and um we're
referring to there's a class note for
the 504 line
um oh wait I'm sorry for the 506 line
um
right so so we we cannot use these funds
for any other purpose
um in in the CFI line we are projecting
about a four million dollar lapse right
now
so so is there a proposal to to strike
234 or to amend it to reduce amounts or
is or are we all aligned on the
potential of keeping it as is
considering it's 12 o'clock and we have
a caucus I think it might be worthwhile
discussing with the information we have
before we proceed
okay so we'll we'll we'll hold on that
as well I'm going to call us into recess
um Mr Ripple I'm confused about
technicalities what I want to say is
we're going to recess until Finance is
done and then we'll come back but I've
also been told that I need to specify a
specific time that we're going to be
back so I think recessing until the full
Finance meeting is complete is fine okay
we will recess until the full finance
all right uh 337 and I'm going to bring
us out of uh recess
um that that that recess took a little
longer because uh both parties had to
caucus and we had to caucus longer
apparently
so uh
I think
I need to figure out where I am
we
so Mr Ripple I'm gonna I'm gonna go
through these and tell you and have you
tell me if we made a decision already or
if we still need to discuss and vote
okay
I I think I think we
took a vote no we did we deferred item
49 and 50 on the peer-to-peer we
deferred that that's correct you haven't
taken a vote yet
Okay so we've we've did we just we did
discuss it is there any further
discussion on whether or not we want to
keep
I I I think I think I'd like to remove
this and the reason for it is it's a new
program and we need to find some money
to Target towards Medicaid so is there
okay do you okay
um all right so let's take a straw vote
um
those in favor
of deletion of for the 45 and 50 raise
your hand please
for didn't I say 49 or 50.
oh did I well it's that mental illness
okay so uh opposed
okay there's and then walner and then
okay no that's all right so so so you
got that then Mr Ripple we're going to
delete that yes okay then the next one I
have a bunch of scribbles around is uh
226 Health Care Facility workplace
violence prevention program I think when
we left
uh I had shown everyone an amendment and
basically had talked through it
and this is basically
splitting the baby between the
Department's request to suspend the
statute outright and the the private
sector's request that we do not suspend
it that we go ahead and execute it that
what this did representative Wilder
because you weren't here for the
discussion is it essentially
suspends aspects of it for the the this
budget cycle with the idea that we
wanted the the department to budget for
it next time around and then
representative tolersky alertly
identified a couple of things where we
would be killing things in the law
um I I think I just soon vote for this
and and work with representative
tolersky and others to see if we can
correct this in the Senate we just have
too many stragglers at this point to
keep coming back and cleaning it up
so so I would like to
have a straw vote on acceptance of
two three four five opposed
okay uh so that so that passes we'll put
that in
representative I'm serious you can
either do it with with me or without me
I don't I don't I don't care whatever
your preference is but uh if you want to
tweak this to make sure that it's we're
only holding this in advance for this
budget cycle and not permanently I'm I'm
on board with that
okay
um
then we're on 2 30. uh I have scribbles
there established a certain unclassified
positions oh this is these are the
attorneys that we're trying to change
from being hourly employees to salaried
employees
and that is consistent with what many of
us have observed we'd like to have more
salaried employees and fewer hourly
so uh is uh I I would like to have a
straw vote on accepting the Department's
proposal
is there any discussion I apologize I
was taking notes on the amendment that
just passed what section are we on uh we
are on two three zero thank you this is
one of the two lines where we are moving
people from hourly to salaried
and this is the line with the lawyers I
I think it affects 32 lawyers altogether
or at least some percentage of of the
32.
okay do you are you ready do you know
okay so I'd like a straw vote on who's
in favor of accepting the Department's
proposal as written do you have you have
discussion well I just thought that we
had already said keep it we didn't vote
we'll put it back on this no there was
this morning there were two okay okay
and I know there's two twenty years and
representative whole asked for us to
reconsider uh 2 30. he was okay with 239
230 or is the lawyer line
okay okay so I'm voting to keep it I I
am asking for a straw vote on whether
you want to keep it yes okay
okay raise your hand if you're opposed
okay
um now we're on 232 carry forward of
funds and the developmental Services uh
acquired brain disorder and In-Home
Support 232 is this one that you to talk
232. is this the one that you had in a
couple of amendments prepared with Mr
Ripple
so yes so you guys just do this
conversation and we'll listen
you want me to hand out both the house
bill 2 and House Bill one component
down the line or are we going to go back
I think I flagged a one earlier in the
list that I wanted to look at again I I
was trying to go sequentially did I did
I but now I look at it did I skip over
the Choose Love yeah he did
oh yeah we'll come back I don't I meant
I won't interrupt
in representative hole I think I cut you
off on 2 30. if you had if you want to
come back and explain your opposition
I'd be okay with doing that it's just I
feel like we're really under time
pressure to to move
okay
okay so I'm going to give you the
concept first just to remind everybody
and then I'll go through
the details
there are three accounts in the in the
DD world that are continually
appropriated
one and second they must be budgeted to
the full
amount
of the need as opposed to the the amount
that can be delivered
okay
with that in mind
these amendments
are looking only at this the three
accounts but only at this biennium's
amount that would be
rolled forward they're continually
appropriated forward piece so these are
essentially the estimated numbers
of what I would refer to as the lapse in
and that total net amount
is about 25
million dollars
and the idea is to
push that forward into the same it's
actually more like we'll come to the
totals it's actually more like 28
million dollars is a sum of three
numbers here
um but before I get to the details push
that forward into each of the accounts
and call under agency income
and then subtract out the general the
equivalent general fund income in each
of those accounts so the idea is you'll
see when I go through in detail which I
will you'll see that it frees up General
funds in the same amount that we're
pushing forward so if we start with the
first of the hb1 Amendments that are
that's the ones that are stapled
together
you'll see a couple things first of all
for that account
you'll there's that's the one that has
the initial 25 million in it you'll see
under 2024 change
you'll see a 25 million dollar change to
the positive under agency income so
that's the money flowing in
from this year
and then down below under beside General
funds you'll see 25 million dollar
released if you will to General funds
and what we're going to talk about here
is not going to get into the Medicaid
rate increases but the intent is that
these
funds are being freed up for exactly
that purpose so that we'll have them
available to us when we come to that
discussion later on and so if you just
flip to the next page you'll see the
same thing going on with the with the
nine hundred thousand dollars
flowing into agency income a 900 and
freed up in general funds for that
account and then on the third page same
thing 2.7 million dollars flowing in in
agency income and 2.7 million be freed
up in general funds and if you then look
above on each of those under the
description
you'll see there's a footnote and Mr
White has been through this as well I'm
sure he'll speak to it but I believe he
is
um I'll let's just say agnostic for the
moment
um but this this note you can read it
for yourself I want well I'll just read
it in the event that expenditures are
greater than the amounts appropriated
the commissioner May request with prior
approval of the fiscal committee that
the governor and Council authorize
additional funding upon fiscal period
the upon fiscal committee and government
Council approval the governor's
authorized to draw a warrant for any
money in the treasury not otherwise
appropriated in other words if those
accounts in the next biennium run short
they can request additional money from
General funds to make up a difference
so um I guess your starting point is
you're saying this 25 million which is
expected to be uh um not fully utilized
in the end of 2023 uh despite that
um the budget that we're getting
um uh or the the current uh hb1 Bill
requires us is to put in the full amount
not taking into account any lapsed funds
that are specifically targeted uh to
developmentally disabled so that I think
there's a two-part answer to that
question
the budget as produced and Mr White
record I'm wrong here the budget is
produced for 24.25 already includes all
the funds necessary to address all of
the need they anticipate in the next
biennium
however because of the way this law is
set up in addition to that whatever was
not spent from this biennium would flow
forward on top of all that into the next
by name that's why I understand it and
if Mr White wants to interrupt me he can
foreign
so just to recap
um some of the requirements so
as representative Earth uh accurately
indicated
um RSA 171a requires that we submit a
fully funded budget
um for to to make sure that that we that
we don't have a waiting list um the
three accounts the DD account the
children's IHS account the acquired
brain disorder account are continually
appropriated non-lapsing accounts and
and the amounts that you see included in
the amendment before you are the general
fund portion of what we expect lapse
did that answer your questions
we're saying the 25 million is what you
expect to lapse
or not to lapse in this case sure and
and and that that 25 million that is the
general fund portion we we would
um of course have the have the matching
federal dollars associated with that
that that we would um
uh potentially need to expend as well
and on on pages on the subsequent pages
of the hb1 amendment you also have the
nine hundred thousand dollars with the
acquired brain disorder uh Services
account as well as the children's
In-Home Support Services account as well
um and just one technical issue
um I my assumption is you would want
that footnote to to be a class note tied
to class 502. in each account
Mr Robert can you make note of that
yes
so good there's one other part okay I I
I I I just want to do some of the back
end on this for people's perspective in
the committee uh so that the shorthand
on this is that the legislature
compelled itself to fully fund the
entire wait list
and whether they're uh
provider shortages or not we're required
to fund the entire wait list
and
we oversight gets regular updates HHS
oversight it's regular updates and the
department
proudly says we've we've completely
funded the wait list and so the
oversight committee keeps asking yes but
how many are effectively backlogged
because we don't have providers
available to take the money and provide
the services
and we've asked in three consecutive
quarterly reviews by the department and
they've not been able to answer that
fundamentally and and critically
important question so I'm bringing this
up now also to just say if you could go
back
oversight doesn't need to keep hearing
that it's fully funded because we know
that we've done that by law what we need
to be able to know as part of the
ongoing status reports is exactly how
many are getting services and how many
we know of that need services that
cannot because there's not providers
available it's it's that that we need to
understand and help help is the
oversight committee to regulate so so
I'm I'm really comfortable with the idea
that we we've got money that we can pull
forward out of the balance of this term
and put into the next term to basically
meet our obligations on their law and
still have some budgetary flexibility so
I appreciate you and Miss Mr Ripple
having worked together on this so far
and I hope those were helpful comments
to everyone and then I I think he still
wanted to talk about the other piece of
this
thank you so just to complete the
process and the other piece of paper
um Amendment 1064
H is to the hb2 is to the actual section
we're talking about section 232. and
this basically puts into hb2 the process
I just described to you whereby the
funds will be picked up
from each of those three accounts and
transfers forward into the 2024 agency
are you done no I think so unless Mr
I have a question of Mr White
so
as I look at this how does this at all I
would this change affect the matching
amount of money
for to receive the federal money
no
whether in our state's accounting system
if it's considered other or general it's
still the state share for the matching
portion okay so I think a similar
example is how how we receive the the
dollars from the counties and then we
match that so you know it's other other
funds so no there would be no no
no effect on the federal funds
no it would still be the state shares so
okay thank you
for uh representative Stringham uh just
to be make sure I'm clear so so we would
still be fully funding
um the the disability uh the DD
developmentally disabled uh budget this
year
um
with with no further
we don't have to add any more money into
this year's budget to compensate for
this no based on on current projections
we would still be good the governor's
budget had assumed that these carry
forward funds that that we're talking
about
um were addressed through an hb2
provision uh here you're seeing them
show up in hb1 as as that restricted
Revenue as directed through that second
so the hb2 provision that you're
referring to is 232 right
and and what uh representative erf has
done is he's recommended a change to the
so representative ulner I
I'm I'm feeling anxious to be voting
things but uh do you want to sleep on
this overnight and vote on it tomorrow
mind doing that
I would really I really really want to
think about this one for well and you
probably want to make some phone calls
just to make sure that it works the way
we've described it here thank you yeah
representative Stringham well I noticed
I notice Alex is here and I'm pretty
sure when he came in he didn't have any
uh whiskers so
um and the four o'clock shadow is
definitely uh reached us but do you have
any comments on this and it would be I
would or or anybody else I'll invite you
come on up Mr chair okay
good afternoon Alex katrubis I represent
the area agencies uh
I mean I've just seen this and I was not
aware that it was being drafted so I
don't necessarily have a final answer
for you I do have a couple of questions
that maybe the CFO of the department
would be able to answer
and I think it's what you were saying
representative Stringham if your
questions are for Mr White let's just
hold up for a moment because they're I
don't want to interrupt what they're
doing either
okay so Mr White
uh Alex would like to ask some questions
that he thinks that you're the one that
so if this was to be adopted
will it will we have enough funds in
these accounts to fund these students
who are going to be graduating from
Special Ed
in the spring
sure so our videos of the biennium yep
so our original agency budget had
included funds for that purpose
um the governor's budget again you
weren't seeing these in hb1 what
representative Earth's series of
amendments do is bring those forward
into into hb1 partially as restricted
Revenue
and have you looked at the uh the Seas
so for for those that are in the system
now that need enhanced services
is there any modeling to make sure
there's enough dollars to take care of
those for the next two years sure my
understanding is is when the team came
up with the amounts that are included in
the budget they looked at utilization
and they looked at those that they
expected to age into the system I think
I think one of the challenges that you
know we've had is we submitted our
agency budget back back in the um you
know back in August and then we had some
additional revisions during the
governor's phase just as those numbers
move throughout the budget
and the last question I had
representative Edwards is I guess I'm
unclear how would this actually
is there going to be a percent that the
DD rates would go up under this plan I
don't I guess I'm unclear what the
impact would be okay so the rate issue
is totally separate all of all that
we're talking about now is accounting
for the money that we are obligated to
set aside to pay for the wait list
and and given that we're so close to the
end of the budget cycle we can now see
that excess amount that we set aside for
the wait list we're comfortable that
under current scenarios everyone who
needs their services are going to get
their services that'll still free up
like 28.6 million dollars since we have
the same obligation and the next budget
to fully fund the wait list we have to
come up with the same total amount of
money that the department has projected
but this will let us do is basically
move that 28.6 this is where it gets
really wonky
and I hopefully got it right what it
does is it lets us move that 28.6
million into other Area Agency Revenue
that reduces our general fund obligation
between those two we have to come up to
the same total and we do that
by doing that that frees up effectively
28.6 million dollars in the next budget
that was already that was sort of
obligated or tied down when we when we
free up that 28.6 million in general
fund that gives us some options on how
to invest that into something else and
right now there's something else the
highest priority to me seems to be the
targeted Medicaid rates but that's a
different decision than what we're
making right here so I I guess just to
summarize uh members of the committee I
think from the area agency perspective
this is a I think an idea that has a lot
of Merit if we can make sure that all of
the new people who are going to be
graduating and exiting School are going
to be taken care of and the individuals
who are in the system now who have a
significant life change which is what is
in RSA 171a if you're in the system now
and you have a significant change to
your condition will there be dollars to
support enhanced Services if both of
those are taken care of under this and I
think it's smart to have the language in
there about the fiscal Committee in case
we do get this wrong uh so I I think we
would be I can't say it for certain
because I haven't asked anyone about
this yet but I think the idea has a lot
of Merit but I think those would be our
two primary concerns that the new folks
coming into the system and then the
existing folks making sure that there's
enough if they need enhanced services so
so I would encourage you to talk to
folks this evening and we're we're going
to hold off at representative Waller's
request to vote on this tomorrow think
about it and to the extent that uh
Mr White to the extent that there's a
good question here about the graduates
and everything if you could just
validate you know tomorrow that you guys
have believed that you have it covered
that all of the requirements for the
current year are going to be taken care
of while we still liberate this money in
the next budget cycle
is okay
all right do you have anything who who
has a question representative Weiler
I think the problem is not the money but
the personnel unless you can do
something about that with your area
agencies
we obviously haven't been able to
fulfill that that's why we have money
lapsing forward as a shortage of primary
caretakers and
I'm hoping your agency can help yeah I
absolutely agree I think representative
Edwards was I think at the Forefront of
this you know after the last budget was
passed that at HHS oversight yes the
wait list is zero technically all that
means is that folks have funding
allocated to them they're not actually
necessarily in program receiving
services on a daily basis and you're
absolutely right it's been a major
problem so I applaud this effort I think
it's it's creative it's we have to look
at doing things differently because
continuing elapsed tens of millions of
dollars every biennium doesn't make a
lot of sense so I think it's absolutely
worth exploring I just want to do some
double checking to make sure
all right that sounds good did you have
a follow-up representative Weiler if not
I'll go to representative erf
so since representative Wildlife brought
I would just like to reiterate
that the whole point of this
is to free up Monies
to increase rates not just in this in
this area but across all these areas so
that more services can be provided
so there isn't the money that's just
sort of sitting in the bank at the end
of the biennium which could have been
used to
get more services across the board
that's really the goal here
thank you all right so I think we're in
violent agreement and we're not going to
vote on this this afternoon we're going
to go home think about it sleep on it
and then so it'll be in the white space
tomorrow Mr Ripple
um and then let's go back to choosing
love
um item 212 for some reason I just
skipped over it in my eye
um
now the original
decision on choosing love was we we're
going to delete this
it's not much money
the governor's office over lunch
spent some more time talking with me
talking about how important it is the
governor to get this into
DHHS and it's a tiny amount of money
and it's one big team effort so you know
I I think there are people that want the
program I know the governor's office
wants the the program
so uh if we were to instead of deleting
this if we were to keep the proposal
instead of deleting it
you're opposed to keeping it could you
want to say why you would have post
keeping it
just goes along with My Philosophy that
we should
be
eliminating things to put towards the
Medicaid rate stuff and the governor
apparently has this money in his budget
and I don't see why he couldn't either
use it or give it to DHHS so they can
I think that's a really good point I I
you know the independent of the decision
to move it in the department why aren't
we pulling money from the governor's
budget to support it so this should have
a net state budget impact of zero we're
just moving the money but it looks like
we're spending additional money here is
there a compatible decrease in the
governor's office so it Nets out a zero
I I don't know the answer to that I
don't know Kevin if you know what
division one has said I don't know
either you know what it's such a tiny
amount of money I don't know that I'd
obsess about it representative Weiler
I've never heard a good description of
what this program does
we we we had um I forget her name we had
the program director in here earlier
today and the way she described it uh is
a uh a train the trainer kind of program
where
um she uh gets counselors to understand
a different type of counseling to
identify people who have social
emotional needs that are not being met
and that she coaches them up that will
not she but the program Choose Love
coaches them up and reduces things like
aggression so for example she she did
offer some metrics related to
residential facility living where they
claim and I don't have any reason to not
believe it but but they they've claimed
that they reduced aggressive behaviors
and I'd call the the numbers substantial
like you know in one unit of time
previous they had something like 84
incidents of aggression Airman after
this program got rolled out that dropped
to something like six over the same
amount of time so so they did offer some
success metrics yes sir what what is
your question it sounds repetitious with
standard of care
system of care I think you probably mean
that's what I meant system of care the
one that's supposed to keep him out of
the
the youth detention
well so so this also includes people who
are already incarcerated so they're
going into the prisons and I don't want
to be the person to go into the prison
to say choose love but somebody's brave
enough to do that uh representative I
just wanted to add what little bit I
know about the program which is was born
out of a anti-bullying
um platform I think branching off of an
increase in youth suicides and trying to
reach not necessarily children who may
be geared towards
um incarceration so much as kids in the
school system kids on the playground
um really trying to meet them in the in
the classrooms or in the youth centers
in the YMCAs and the Boys and Girls
Clubs and to build up that kind of skill
learning for de-escalation and a caring
and kindness program and it has proven
to be quite successful so I would be
again voting to keep it in the budget if
that question was asked
although if there was a way to figure
out how to keep it in the governor's
office I would be interested in hearing
about it
I think the governor's office said that
they don't really have the right policy
person and that they've done their sort
of uh try it before you buy it program
and they think it's a success and they
want to go embed it somewhere on a more
permanent basis I think representative
Rottweiler offers an interesting
point though and that is it's starting
to feel redundant with some other things
that should be happening that we hear
are happening in the whole system of
care area and uh and and I do think that
would be worth watching and having the
department pay attention to over the
coming budget to see if there's there is
redundancy in there where we're you know
we're not adding stove pipes but we're
continually trying to integrate programs
um so so I would I would be in favor of
of instead of deleting line
212 on choose love I would be in favor
of flipping that and retaining it at
half a million dollars to or excuse me
five five hundred thousand dollars total
is there any opposition go ahead
no opposition
um my question is is it possible for Mr
Ripple to find out where in hb1 this
money came from so then when we meet as
a full Finance we can either somehow
pull the money from the governor's
current that current Department to fund
this I'm not it's not about the program
it's about it was in the executive
branch and somehow it now is moving over
and I'd like to make sure that the
executive branch didn't take the 150 000
and use it for something else so I think
we agree uh the only open question to me
is the timeline of him doing the
homework I would I would like to make
sure that Mr Ripple is able to
prioritize his time to getting this
budget ready for us to send a full
Finance I don't know that this is an
issue that would hang us up but
something we should know about before we
get all done
well I can find out where it was funded
previously in the governor's office and
if that's something you'd like to take
up next week during the full committee
hearings you can do that
okay that'd be fine
Okay so
straw vote on the uh telersky amendment
to retain 212. raise your hand
I choose love you choose love okay uh
opposed
um
we didn't finish the county cap did we
say that we were going to talk about the
county cap tomorrow or did we finish it
oh yeah that was eight to nothing we
loved that one I see my note now okay
so 234 choices for independent program
CFI
and I know we've talked about this five
times but my mind is just blank I think
part part of the issue is whether
whether this dovetails with the rate
changes and whether adding this funding
which we're being told is entirely due
to increased volume
uh in in this piece should be
broken out separately as it is in this
line item in hb2 or included in rate
change or a little bit of both
um and um
uh there there may be some people here
that can that can you know comment on on
what the CFI program needs and whether
the requested change in rates plus this
requested change are are in any way
overlapping
Nathan may have uh CFO may have uh
um advice on that as well so the CFO
doesn't have the spreadsheet we got from
the Medicaid payer Community or payee or
recipient Community the the providers I
I think in CFI I'm remembering 7.6
million was a request in year one for
CFI and the related program was another
2.6
uh bringing it to 9.3 right yeah yeah so
so this is this is in the 15 range
um and I and to your point I don't have
it clear in my head whether this money
is it would would basically be the money
that would support that request that was
made by the community or whether this
would then turn out to be incremental
money representative erf could I ask Mr
you sent me a response that relates to
this I mean let me read it to you I made
me misinterpreting the context
um but what you wrote was following up
on the request relative hb2 section 234
and how these funds could be used to
increase CFI rates
if we were to use the 15 million GF
appropriation for CFI rate increases we
could increase rates by at least four
percent over the biennium
so is that in juxtaposition to how you
want to use these because you actually
have more potential to get to you have
the Staffing to actually spend currency
of fire rates to address more CFI
situations
sure so just a couple of points of
clarity
um one the reason this is an hp2
provision is because it would not fit
within our efficiency budget to
this these amounts pay partially for
current projected Services as well as an
increase what we would anticipate to be
an increase in utilization and one of
the conversations that I've you know I
I've had with the team is we don't have
a demographer
um for better for worse and so you know
we're making estimates when it comes to
these figures based on the best
information that we have available so if
you
um
and then the service question are there
are there providers in the community to
provide these Services
um you know we're starting to move into
the policy realm there because I don't
have perfect information
um I know that you've heard from from
the community where the rates aren't
sufficient to be able to attract
individuals to provide those services so
we're we're kind of moving into the
tricky realm of it's it's almost the
Catch-22 realm of do you do you provide
do you provide a rate increase and
assume those Services won't be provided
or do you fund it at what we would
anticipate the the service need to be at
and I don't have a perfect answer there
um but but but if as I stated in the
email if if we were to convert these
dollars for the purposes of rate
increase
um you know we we could pick up that
percentage we just we run the risk of
our projected need and utilization
so it might be possible and I realize
you imperfect a lot of guessings going
on but it might be possible to
break this up into two components one of
which would be
more services
the other which we could then use to
apply to rate increases as part of the
whole Medicaid rate increase expansion
may I try and answer that
um I think if there are if there aren't
additional providers in the community
putting more money into chasing the
utilization number
it doesn't really get us very far I
don't see a lot of traction there
but if we took additional money and we
increased the rates a little bit then we
could anticipate a little bit more
utilization and if we increase the rates
even greater then we could assume even
greater utilization it almost feels like
this there's this upward curve as we
improve rates our utilization is going
up and we don't have
the algorithm to figure out what that is
it's a sort of a best guess kind of
thing so what I would propose us doing
is taking this money from here
and putting it over into tomorrow's
discussion on on Medicaid Target rates
taking a look at what the community
requested taking a look at these these
monies and having us do sort of the
Kentucky windage best guess on what rate
increases might do to drive utilization
go ahead I respond so that's essentially
what I was asking
um you don't want to put it all under
rate increases or you can't expand
utilization and and I realized it'd be I
can't remember what your sweet term was
for
yeah
um but that's sort of what I was asking
Miss what if you could possibly do in
other words do we leave a little bit in
here
for additional utilization based on the
fact that when we do the
the rate increases we're hoping to do in
this account and others
that we'd have more people coming in
to do the jobs
and this increase the utilization
so it sounds that there's a trade a
little bit of a trade-off there of
dollars in each place
what are your thoughts Sir Mr White
that's sort of on the Fly is it is there
worth about is there value added by
keeping it stink saying okay here's some
money for utilization realizing that we
also are going to have a a partner part
of it on targeted rate increases and so
somehow we got to get those two numbers
aligned to where we think if we raise
the target so much we need we're going
to actually be able to achieve greater
utilization what what are your thoughts
what if I put together tonight a couple
of scenarios where we go if if we were
to split the difference and go 50 50 75
it it sounds like that's what you're
looking for like if if we were to take
50 and put it towards existing services
and take 50 and put it towards rates
what would those numbers look like what
would those percentage increase look
like on the rate side I can put a model
together for the committee to consider
um just understanding that you know we
still have those risks as to whether we
fund Services adequately or we over fund
Services it's that I I don't know if
there's a perfect answer at this point
I'm sure there's not but but having that
information I think Mike give us a
better shot of finding good balance for
all of us yourself included the
department included yes I guess I'm
going to go Stringham Weiler Waller okay
alphabetical not quite uh
um I I guess the concern I have is that
your estimate here was uh you know based
on real numbers and you know maybe
there's been growth uh in this previous
Bonet uh biennium in these services so
that you're seeing a higher rate of
utilization of the CFI program right now
and it's actually picked up a lot of the
slack from lack of long-term nursing
beds and other services uh that have um
uh going down in the last few years so
um and um so I don't know if you have
any comments on
how you uh project the current level of
utilization with these numbers or how
much of this is really new new
um from where we are now not where we
averaged over the two-year biennium and
um
in in any other factors that went into
the projected increase
sure so I I think
um
I think from a path forward perspective
what what what I want to do is talk to
the team
and look at what do we have for
utilization to date for this year
because again this is for the agency
it's an 18-month process and so these
these numbers do and nobody ever wants
to hear this but these numbers do change
throughout that process because of that
so what I'd like to do is is talk to the
team get the most accurate information
that we have to date and then give give
this committee a series of options
um and if there's a strong indicator one
way or another I'll give a
recommendation
okay okay I appreciate that because we
you know we had considered uh that this
need was separate from the need to
change rates is the way the way that
I've been thinking about it I I think
we're still basically there but
representative Weiler
I think there's a relation between the
empty nursing home beds and the choices
for Independence
if we go up in the Medicaid rates and
more nursing home beds become available
some of the people that are in choices
for Independence will likely be waiting
for those nursing home beds
that may affect the thing is and I also
have a question about
years ago I remember that
one woman I know was was recruited from
an elderly neighbor that she knew well
to say can you come and do my laundry
once a week and she's agreed to it and
got paid through this program or some
program that it made it made both of
them more comfortable both because
a lot of elderly people don't want a
stranger in their home and is it
possible to have somebody that they
recruit come in without going through a
lot of rigmarole to get a license and a
I I that's really getting the
programmatic aspects of it Henry you
I I I could bring in uh the program side
to talk specifics of of the of the
program but but that's beyond my beyond
oh okay so in summary what I think we
decided to do with this is uh go back
you're going to try to figure out some
sort of algorithm on how we can drive
Target rate increases and and what it's
going to do on utilization and try to
come up with sort of two numbers that
ought to be paired with one another does
that sound right yep yep and we'll look
at utilization to date but but again
initially this was for projected
utilization it's just that we'll we'll
look at whether any of the updated
figures will give us a better indicator
as to whether these numbers have changed
since since January and I fully
appreciate that we're definitely into
the area of wag so we're not going to be
precise right we're just going to try to
figure out the best using your best
judgment I think and then if we could
get the CFI director back to just
you know to help address some of
Representative Weiler's concerns we're
going to do that tomorrow
I I would park this at this point then
right
all right uh
so now
I see us down on 254.
the Family Resource Center
infrastructure a million and a million
and we we held this one
who who remembers why we held this
probably because of me go ahead well I
just I suggested deletion and just take
a vote just take a vote I think that's
what you're done arguing okay so so the
proposal is to delete item 254. if
you're in favor of deleting someone else
might want to make a different motion I
the sense of the committee might be the
opposite I know okay but there's only
two choices you know we eliminate one
the other one's true right
yeah
are we still holding did you guys talked
about this didn't you
yeah I think you're set so uh if you are
so there's four if you are in
oh wait did you want this is yeah we did
it the other way we said we're this are
you in favor of deleting and you did not
raise your hand right now the other
question is are you in favor of keeping
254.
so it is four to three
I exercise a discretion not to vote on
I don't want to vote on that I don't I
don't I don't know enough about this
program
I will however recognize it represent in
norgreness with us
and I suspect she would vote as
representative tolerski would so how did
you vote you voted to keep this so we
got four to four we're still on hold
well I'm getting ready to vote with uh
yes so now it's four four
that means there is no decision that
means we have to talk about it and vote
on it again tomorrow when representative
norgren is here uh everyone can go do
their homework and make sure they're
all right
um
okay I think we are on 253 which was the
increase of Medicaid provider rates
we're going to have a big session on
that tomorrow I believe is that right
no I meant to say 257 I don't know what
number I said 257 is the Medicaid rates
representative Stringham are you going
to have some proposal for us to consider
tomorrow because because we we do have
uh a draft amendment that we're still
working on it divides rate increases
into time 19 broader categories
largely based on the input that we got
from from Mr Monahan so you have you
have you have specific uh targets and
you have specific targeted rates
for us to look at tomorrow yeah what we
have is
um mostly is just this this particular
um you know budget area and how much
additional money would be dedicated in
that category to increase rates so
what's your total just ballpark what's
your general total new funding
um it's just barely south of 200 million
over two years okay
all right we should talk about that
that's real money good uh representative
since
I think he's still here because we at
least hear what he has to say he might
be able to just give us some broad brush
information something to say to us we
have we may have some questions for you
so you've been here a couple times today
so we figured we'd get you up and get
good afternoon for the record Henry
do either of you have a question that
you'd like addressed well I guess I
would start with have you seen the this
Monahan document that we're we've been
tossing around here yes
um I believe if it's the one that was as
late as uh
Thursday or Friday of last week dated as
the one I've seen March 16th is the one
I have maybe that's the same one I think
okay and that was the email that I sent
to you reflecting that I don't have any
chance to read it but maybe you could
discuss the email you sent to me sure
and and in the context of this uh
uh uh document sure
um it
came to my attention we have um in the
group of providers that are on this list
there's a agency that's basically our
soul Source Agency for personal care
assistance under state plan
um and Grant State Independent Living
they do such tasks as when someone say
is a paraplegic in needs you know is
totally dependent on someone doing like
I'm not trying to be crude here but
bowel removal in this Pacman and other
kind of real personal care that they
were not included in the state plan side
of it they were included on the CFI side
of it but that's
um
you know in the context I know you're
not going to take necessarily all of the
requests but if you were to scale it as
the same as the other agencies that
would affect it by three million dollars
in terms of what
um
what would be on that list more in terms
understate plan to to handle that
particular group and and these are
people that are really on the lowest end
of the pay scale of providing these
Services you know the 12 14 kind of
range so it's one and a half million in
each of the two years of by your name is
that who you're looking at it or three
million I'm looking at um three million
three million because it would be the
same character for each year okay a
question we do have private duty nurses
as a separate category yes and that's
generally what Granite State you know
they have different categories of um
uh of support at home whether it's you
know just going shopping together or
actually providing nursing Services I
think would would that have already been
included under the private duty nurses
or when they fall under the granite
state umbrella would it be um would that
be an addition do you think so when I
was here Friday I I had a chance to talk
to Kate and to then go back and talk to
the executive director of the agency and
that's where I I came back with uh the
information that I had and it's it's
really the it's the low end people on
the pay scale that do that very personal
type care that keep people who are
otherwise be institutionalized
um and uh you know they're having a hard
time you know when you talk about sort
of rate increases like if the rate isn't
High Enough of an increase then it's not
going to make a difference on
utilization because they're not going to
great great
um and uh if we're going to put that in
as a line item how would you describe it
um
state plan PCA Services personal care
do you have a follow-up your mic still
on
uh representative Weiler
isn't this what representative erf just
found and carry forward on the
developmentally disabled found 28.6
million was it for this purpose well
for this broader purposes so I'm not
sure if you'll hear representative when
we or chairman Wyler when uh women over
money Mr Monahan's document which goes
across all the various Medicaid not all
but many of the rate increases that they
were proposing and this is this would be
one component of it so yes the funding I
was pulling out of there is to be a
piece of this but we're trying to get as
much funding available so the week so in
the Monahan document itself it was
budgeting something on order of what uh
representative Stringer was uh
spring them sorry string them
I'm sorry it's late
um his document had about 100 million
each of the two years and we're we're
probably not quite there but um the idea
is to get as much into the pool from my
point of view that is as much into the
pool as possible for that purpose
that's what I thought thank you
Mr chairman just just one second so so
we have a benchmark from representative
Stringham that was just south of 200
million for the two for total for the
two years right
yes and um we're we were having some
discussion too on how quickly any rate
changes could be implemented yeah which
may bring that's an interesting point
first year a bit so
um so that is a great question uh
representative before we get to that
great question what sort of ballpark are
you feeling that we're gonna you think
we're gonna be at
I'm not quite there yet in terms of
having a ballpark
um I mean we've tossed around 40 but I
don't know that doesn't come from
anything like that in terms of numbers
so when I played with this again the
other night and sent it out I was I was
feeling about 62 million I saw that that
was scaring me I know that's why I'm
glad you found the extra 28. are you
welcome uh so Mr lippman you can say
what you want and then you can maybe
also talk to us about the lag between us
having it and the budget and you being
able to uh affect rates so just first
thing I want to do is clarify uh
representative while when you were
talking about
um the DD and all that that the services
I was talking about were outside of that
it's when it's delivered through state
plan like through the Managed Care
Program is is what I was referring to
the things that are providing waiver are
accounted for
um and so I think in terms of
of uh the magnitude
of of rate changes that I think are
being contemplated whatever the figure
ends up being
um it there's quite a bit of work to be
done and depending on on
how you target it could require us to to
make additional changes so I think we do
need at least minimally a quarter to
from the time that the budget is signed
in assuming it's signed into law on time
we need a quarter I think to effectuate
um you know all the things that we need
to do in terms of
um unlike some systems that I'm familiar
with are our mmis system requires us to
put in
uh not like a system where you can just
sort of upload all the rate changes and
it happens like this like I used to be
able to do it's it's a more clunky kind
of thing you have to go in and change
each item in there so it's a it's a a
large uh effort so I think in terms of
working on the rate increases maybe we
could do some right away
um and the the you know when I say right
away within a very short time and it
take us a little bit of time I think to
get it's like 13 000 codes to update and
maybe one strategic approach could be
you know when
um representative Edwards uh the chair
had identified you know what your 80 20
rule you know you could do approach it
like like that and you know move things
a little faster along but I think we
definitely
um be a hard lift to implement
everything in you know July one so so
how would you prefer to roll out rate
increases let's say we got a 100
procedure codes we want to affect would
you would you want to have a later date
were you confident you could have them
all done and turned on on one day like
one January or something or would you
rather do a rolling change to the rates
to just try to take care of the most
significant ones first to have the
biggest impact fastest which would you
which of those approaches would you like
the latter which is to roll it out so we
have time to get to the most critical
areas the quickest because I think you
know in terms of
costs of the state that when you know
patients can't be discharged to nursing
homes or when people can't be accepted
into the CFI program because of rates or
people can't be discharged a home
because there's Home Care available
those are the things that I think are
are backing up the system the most right
now right so so inevitably if you don't
do it all on the same day you're going
to have the people who haven't had it
implemented yelling at you that you're
being unfair and you don't like them so
how how would you deal with that sort of
public criticism I guess I'm prepared to
take the criticism because I think we'd
be doing the right thing for the public
all right uh representative Stringham
and uh you know somewhere between the
Brain Trust of of Kevin and our CFO here
um you know they pointed out that even
if they wanted to implement them on a
certain day some of them have to be go
through a process with CMS to be
implemented so it takes a while to put
in a change it's not like
even if they got the one code they want
to change tomorrow they could couldn't
necessarily do that the basic process is
we have to public notice so when it gets
signed into law then we we public notice
the and then we can get an effective
date that say for example if we knew
what the changes were late June we could
public notice before July 1st and we
could make some rates effective then but
I think just you know realistically
if we're changing it if this rate
increase is going to involve everything
in Medicaid it's that's a big lift and I
think the the rate setting unit is not
that large it's a relatively small group
of people plus we have to continue our
regular course of business while we're
we're doing this
um
so I do think in terms of when you're
you're sizing this in terms of the
the size you can gain some impact by the
time frame it's implemented in in terms
of the net cost in a given period
sure I have a question for Mr Ripple
is does this sound like something that
we should have in our implementing
language whether it's hb2 or detail in
hb1 to to basically ask the department
to have the rate all of the rating
increases we give them implemented no
later than one January or earlier as
possible something something like that
should that should that be in our
Amendment
you could include that language sure
I think there's no reason not to
Okay the reason not to is you'd have to
write it but okay I think one question
would be whether you would want the
rates to be retroactive to the beginning
of the fiscal year or whether you would
want them to go into effect as of the
later date I didn't think about
retroactivity I'm not sure we can do
that but yes the yeah
I don't think you can do that for a lot
of these Services Mr White said no
we'll blame it on him and we'll move on
just to be perfectly transparent you you
could do some things like that but if
this methodology changes that you have
to make and just the ability to pull it
off I think is really the issue at hand
yeah I I I I I think technically we may
be able to do it but logistically if
we're trying to do rate increases across
the board we're going to take away
resources from some of the other actions
and I I would just want to recognize the
administrative hurdles that that the
oh oh okay so I think we have
procedurally that we need to give you
time to roll it out and I just threw a
all done no later than one January as a
as a as an example or could you live
with that yes and the idea that you
would Implement whatever on a
prioritized basis whatever you could
earlier if possible yes
yes questions representative pilersky
now I'm just wondering how we can
have that Translate
to dollar amount so that we can save a
little bit of money in the delayed
rollout and how we identify what
that amount of money
is have you ever heard of the acronym
wag yes I have
so I guess we I guess I would be curious
to have a recommendation from the
professionals there if
if they want to take a wag at it
I I think they would need to okay so
here's the challenge we have to be done
because we're out of time so we have to
agree on an hb2 item and so
uh I don't I I just don't know how much
time we have to spin this at this point
to come up with the amount that we agree
to put into this and then have them do
the analysis on how rapidly it would get
consumed for a ballpark we could just
say skip a half a year of funding
I know but but based on the fact that he
can do a phased an incremental rollout
and if he takes the most expensive ones
first then that screws up don't forget
the sentence going to play with this
that's I guess that's true I I don't
know well let's think about it I think I
think I think we got to just figure out
how much money we got to work with and
realize that it's going to roll out at
an uneven Pace over the first six months
yeah but we should take a stab at it
like say a third or say a quarter say
something because you're right it'll
give us more we'd have bigger bang for
the buck if we account for the fact that
we're not going to spend the first part
of it yeah
all right so we'll talk about this some
tomorrow if you all have inputs since
you're the professionals I guess the
distinction is that you get paid to do
all right are you are you satisfied with
that or where we're at we're going to
come back to this tomorrow that's fine I
do just you know I felt like that
conversation started as a money-saving
you know proposal I was just trying to
figure out where we got to which was
nowhere I mean not nowhere but you
follow me I I I I I I can imagine it
felt that way but in my head I enjoyed
the journey and where I ended up was
that uh whatever amount that we allocate
is actually going to go
it's going to have a bigger impact
because of the delayed rollout it you
know yep yes sir thank you oh we got one
more
okay do it all right
so
284. this is on how much time do you
have sir
five minutes okay this is on uh 284 this
is on the word immediate the use of the
word immediate and I had some suggested
Melissa Saint Sierra
and I think I I tried to email it all to
you so if you guys are are able to check
it
and people keep emailing me saying oh
there it is
all right oh you printed it that's so
good
um okay so keep in mind that the purpose
of 284 was to delete the word
immediately uh from the statute and that
has caused concern that by deleting the
word immediately we're going to create
lethargy when there shouldn't be any so
she went away and she suggested that the
word immediately remains stricken
with the qualifier that delivers such
person as soon it is determined that the
patient is ready for transport and in
the common sense world you can't
transport somebody until they're ready
to transport so so this language
seems okay with me initially but in
talking to Mr and on they really like
that word immediately so so I would even
kind of propose a blending of these two
things to say
continue to leave the word immediately
deleted where it is and it would say
deliver such person immediately upon
determining that patient is ready for
transport
and then I think that meets the intent
of our attorney it meets the desires of
the hospital Association at least it's
my attempt to satisfy them whether they
are or not it's my attempt
and and what what are your thoughts what
are your comments we can have Mr Anand
come up and tell me why he doesn't like
okay so so again I don't know if you
were tracking with us Mr Anon I I am and
again I appreciate your attempt um to
work something out
when I looked against Stephen and
president Hospital Association when I
looked at the quick Amendment on your
phone which is now um written here um
what I looked at was exactly the words
that were being proposed that were being
added
um again the award immediately is
incredibly uh meaningful and I think
needs to remain but what I failed to do
um when I was looking at that so quickly
was looking at the entire language of
what what is in there what was included
in house bill 2. in addition to the word
immediately the the language that says
they will be transported to a when a bed
is available that's new language that is
not current law current law says upon
completion of a voluntary emergency
admission certificate under RSA 135 c28
could you could you just hang on just a
second
because because I'm not seeing one of
bet as oh though I see the phrase
available bed which shall be the closest
geographically with an available bed is
that the yes so where it says you know
first line upon completion volunteer
emergency admissions certificate under
RSA 135 c28 that is current law
the addition of and upon confirmation
that the receiving facility identified
in the certificate which will be the
closest geographically with an available
bed for the person allowing for
participation as a community while
achieving the purposes of Rehabilitation
and treatment that language is new that
language coupled with the word removal
of the word immediately
simply enshrines the system that we've
had for the last decade where patients
were not able to be transported to
receive the care that they need that
that language in its totality is is the
concern that we have
um so again I I appreciate the effort
um but unfortunately should give me just
a moment here I would somebody who has
access to the actual hb2 language that's
in the bill now confirm
what Mr Anand just said is he because
typically when people are providing
additional language they didn't they
will uh bold it the email is not bolded
the way it should be okay it's folded in
hb2 but it wasn't bolded here so on the
email after RSA 135 c28 there should be
bold right before and upon
and then it goes right through the word
treatment comma
should be unlike line four that should
be end bold and then a law enforcement
is existing statute so so I have a
proposal because time is short I I
recommend that we just delete this and
kick it over to the policy committee
this is policy at this point right it's
not money it's a policy so
um so I would I would vote to eliminate
254. is there anyone in the audience
that has a problem with us eliminating
uh is no it's it's 284. I I yeah okay so
so I'm not seeing any movement in the
audience so how in the uh amongst the
the Reps here what is there anyone that
opposes just simply deleting 284 to give
the policy committee the benefit of time
to consider this or the Senate but not
us
okay so raise your hand if you want to
delete 284.
okay done and so miss representative
Weiler thank you so much for your
patience I guess we didn't need you to
stay but I know you want to go
um but I I would like to spend at least
at least 15 more minutes
to well this is why I was going to spend
the next 15 minutes I was going to talk
about where we are with hb1 and what we
can move quickly to saying we agree to
hb1 I I have a proposal
that I would like to accept
I have a proposal that I would like to
accept the governor's hb1 budget
with the exception of any area that
erupt in on this division wants to have
us reconsider on a on a kind of a
section area
but generally assume it to be accepted
and then I have a back of the budget
amendment that I want to share with you
to to familiarize you with it's not
complete though so so Mr Ripple can you
distribute the the back of the budget as
Mr chair go ahead while that's being
delivered right part of the sununu
center budget had a million dollars in
overtime we saw an email earlier today
for not one but two potential scanning
machines for 250 000 each 300 right I
don't think they need one at both doors
right buy one but I think we should
start looking at potential reductions
there why are we planning for a million
dollars of overtime day one that doesn't
sound like a good plan
um and maybe fund that machine instead
and move money around so I think we need
okay so with the provision provision
that we will relook the sununu center
are you otherwise okay with the idea
that we would accept the governor's
proposal on hb1
other than we may have some individual
tweaks we want to discuss and you've
just mentioned the one do you have
another that one I'm not aware of any
others but I'm not sure no
representative erf is very good at doing
this so what are do you have other ones
that you would tweak realizing the back
of the budget is meant to be
a catch-all way
unfortunately I'm not feeling prepared
to answer that question I'm sorry so
I'll tell you what we'll we'll end up
talking about it tomorrow but at least
you'll know where I'm on notice okay
representative
um I have in front of me
an hb1 status of actions related to hp1
and there's a number of prioritized need
requests from the agency that we haven't
discussed that I'm wondering where we're
at with those items
well we've not discussed them but um we
we can if you have specific ones you do
want to discuss I know also that you had
an amendment
so I'm sorry because we were on hb2 and
I forgot to ask you to introduce your
hb2 Amendment
um but so there's two things going on
you you still have your Amendment
Amendment actually they're always
drafted okay
um I guess I'm I'm curious
are we going to go through each I mean
it looks like we still have a good a
good list of things here to review when
you say are we good with the budget as
is to me that means these things are not
included and I feel they haven't been
unless you nominate them for
consideration okay
so do you want to do that tomorrow
give us get prepared to do it tomorrow
or do you want to do it today tonight
I I'm I'm we're here to serve that's
fine I'm just trying to move the work
along okay so in that case you are you
prepared to talk about your hb1
yeah I think this is as good a time as
any
I emailed everyone on Saturday a draft
of an hb1 amendment
um
that would provide funding to the New
Hampshire drug free community coalitions
um I'm passing out a handout which is a
general summary on the um
program but in response to my email
representative Edwards um had some
questions so um the director of the
program has answered all those questions
and I have three pages of answers there
um that maybe they'll
um satisfy the questions maybe they
won't but there they are from the um the
expert of the program
um so basically this is the New
Hampshire drug free Community Coalition
is
um five different
um organizations that come together
to promote
um
and prevent uh substance abuse among
Youth and they've been around for
um almost 20 years the five different
groups are all together in Lebanon Dover
youth to youth National prevention
Coalition Raymond Coalition for Youth
and Southern Rockingham Coalition for
healthy youth in Kingston New Hampshire
um
they had presented to the governor's
Budget Group to be included and believed
that they were included in the budget at
the time and I was notified
from the Nashua group just to make sure
that I knew about it and they were
looking forward to it and wanted to make
sure that I could see it all the way
through after looking further into the
issue with Mr Ripple and Mr White they
were not included in the budget so on
behalf of them I have drafted this
amendment for hb1
which would include These funds it's 625
dollars for each fiscal year totaling
so thank you I've skimmed the answers to
the questions and I generally I I I I
can work with these uh I I I I I'd like
yes or no answers where it says are the
match monies lined up I read this as no
because they haven't yet begun the work
to go get the the extra match monies
lined up yet that that if we give them
this money that you're suggesting
in month a few months time they would
have developed fundraising to get the
match money and then then they would
know whether or not they could get the
match money is it is that
actually I was a little confused by the
answer and the fact that it says match
funding in quotes
is I'm curious if it's not directly
funding so much as uh they they get it
through the identification of activities
and services and I sort of read that as
um
services and and that are organized from
other programs but I agree with you that
um it is unclear
so I don't recall where I read it now I
whether I read it that they actually had
match money that they were looking to go
get and I don't remember where I read
that but that's what triggered the
question
um
and then
question I I think is is a little
circular what happens to the state share
of those contributions don't appear
whatever I read made it sound like you
know they that the state money and the
match money would be put together to
build the program and so it made me
curious if if if we do the state share
and the match money doesn't show up are
we still just committed to spend what
we're going to put in the general fund
to fund it
I agree it was unclear and if you look
at the answer it
it is
doesn't quite say other than their their
ability to provide the services will be
severely impacted so again I cannot
answer that question okay but so you
understand what my question was and you
see the ambiguity and the answer
and again it's not determinative
necessarily but it would help me
understand it
and then there is a question I'm not
sure they addressed and this is this is
kind of a political one so maybe you
would have to do it anyways and that is
this is this is very oh it's not it
isn't you got Dover you got Raymond you
got
you so you've you basically have have
taken this program and you've got little
pockets around the state but it's not
Statewide could you could you talk to us
about whatever process was used to
identify who might be the beneficiary of
the state money this Coalition is made
up of these five organizations that that
work together
it's not your question originally I know
said you thought it was just a Nashua
yeah issue which it's not it's the five
that's why we specified in the amendment
um the five organizations
um that are sort of sprinkled throughout
the state that have found success in the
programming
okay I really appreciate the fact that
you you did get answers and I I think
generally there's a couple with some
ambiguity but
are there other questions about
represent do we is there an actual hb1
paragraph that we should be looking at
so it's just this is this is the only
amendment that we're looking at we don't
have words we don't have the standard
word narrative uh for a house bill one
Amendment no the only narrative here is
the footnote that would be added and
okay so we would change 625 and so that
basically looks like it represents
a quarter at the end of it about a
quarter of what we're going to allocate
are there are there questions about this
proposal I mean we can I I think we
ought to defer it and end up voting
tomorrow so that people can soak on it
but but I think since we're here
together are there any questions that
that we have about this program for
representative tolersky or the
department does the department know
right
I had asked Mr White about it and he had
been unclear as to what we were looking
at
yeah previously um we had communicated
relative to whether there was an
appropriation within the budget for this
program
um and and there was not so this would
so for tomorrow on hb1 we're going to
hear some more details about the sununu
center we're going to come back and and
talk and vote on your proposal here
are there uh specific prioritized needs
you'll want to talk about or are you
going to say I want to talk about each
one
well off the top
of the Ted I know that um since we first
heard about it I have a lot of interest
in trying to figure out how we can
support the WIC supplemental nutrition
program which just has a uh it's a three
hundred thousand dollar
um
appropriate which number is it what line
number is it uh this big long thing I'm
Rick
foreign
number seven on mine oh that's what you
I see zeros though
it was 300 300. 300 and 300. for a total
of six so so it's important to talk
about which ones are these we want to
specifically identify so that if Mr
White has to bring somebody in he's got
heads up so so you want to specifically
talk about line item six the wick
supplemental nutrition program
um
when we heard the presentation from
um the department head
um and heard about how
this would have such a significant
impact on Wellness
particularly childhood Wellness
nutrition and prevention it really
struck with me stuck with me as well as
we already had a bill that I have had a
lot of interest in and when I look at
that price tag for what it would do in
the impact I just would like to have one
last
doesn't sound like we need the director
for that conversation I don't think so
okay all right I think Mr White was here
that day that we talked about it yeah
okay so are there any other of these
line items specifically representative
Waller
do you have a general concept of of what
you think that conversation would look
like
well I know we already do some home
visits and I would just like to have a
conversation about how much additional
home visiting this would purchase for us
how many visits how many families
those kinds of details I'm sure it's I'm
sure it's all been provided within this
stack of stuff so sure it's
approximately 500 children okay
500 children or 500 visits because if
it's children or
this program and and I can certainly
have Trisha Tilley if you if you'd like
to get into the into the weeds a little
bit more
um I I spoke with Tricia about this uh
this program it's a targeted program
it's generally it's a three-year program
where uh where a family child is
involved with the program for three
years and it's um it's it's it's very
specialized in Target to provide support
to that particular family
so it could be 15 per kid over three
years some that that would be the basic
math but the number of children is still
500. roughly yes yeah and so whatever
the number of visits over a three-year
period it's that number times 500 for
total visits
sure I I don't know if those visits vary
between children but yeah okay uh you
have your mic on representative Earth do
all right
um let's talk about Family Planning here
for a second
I forget what we did did I have an
amendment on this that I just haven't
brought forward yet
you do as does representative Earth and
so I'll hand both of those out along
with the Department's requested
technical adjustments to the Family
so so representative we can talk about
your Amendment first but you did you
didn't you didn't you chose not to put
did you choose in your hb1 amendment to
family planning to not include the money
I've been proposing to incentivize new
vendors so correct mine is a very simple
Amendment which has absolutely no impact
on the budget it is a correction to the
federal fund dollars
which as you may recall last Brian there
were some issues where they were
budgeted
um so the bottom line is that
the federal funds if you look down the
very bottom source of funds federal
funds
you'll notice under revised budget in
both years that has 918 140 that's the
actual amount
you can go on the federal website
and see how much is being allocated to
New Hampshire
in the current
I think it's a five-year period and that
period just began if I'm not mistaken
this past year
um in the past when I spoke to this I
talked about
a rollover from one period I think was a
three year period previously to a
five-year period and from my
understanding in a conversation the
conversation is the wrong word
Email exchange between the department
and the federal government
um they did not get a waiver to roll it
between the two periods
they did get away and the periods
included this most recent year that
we're in because it doesn't they overlap
because the federal is on a different uh
you know
year calendar not calendar year but uh
fiscal year than we are
um they did get permission to roll over
160 000 into the current year but that
was only first of all it doesn't matter
because we're budgeting for the next few
years but that wasn't specific to family
planning it was more specific to
software or something like that that
they had to do or auditing or whatever
so basically I was just trying to get
them to
set the federal funds record straight in
terms of
what they can anticipate from the
federal government in 24 and 25 that's
it
okay so this this is actual changes in
the federal funding for Family Planning
Services which is not to be confused
with the direct funding of the
reproductive Health Facilities well so
that's correct there is of course
Planned Parenthood of New England which
is a separate entity they also get
Federal funding and in fact you can it's
not in here obviously but it was
included last time in the budget which
is a mistake you can go on the same
Federal website and I can give you the
link and see the amount they're getting
off the top my head I can't recall what
it was but they're getting something as
well so there is federal funding going
to Planned Parenthood New England and
then there's our what goes on within the
state in terms of what happened last
year and the GNC and all that in terms
of what how they did the up this money
and I'm this is not speak to that at all
so in summary you think this is just an
obvious technical correction to get the
federal numbers right absolutely correct
okay uh I I I'm okay with that are there
questions about that just getting the
numbers right or do you
go ahead
I just think I'd like to
kind of think about it tonight and take
a look at you can give me the the
website
and
has the department excuse me what is one
moment Curtis asked Mr lippman could you
just forward that to everybody because I
sent it to you okay thanks
as a department
weighed in on this I mean do they agree
that this is what they're going to get
from the FED federal government yes
right right now it is technically
accurate um if things change we would
come back through fiscal
so this is an example maybe that since
he started the governor's budget process
so long ago there's been a change in in
what representative Erv has is more
current information than what you
started this budget planning with we had
some email exchanges over over the
summer on this topic looking at how this
has historically been budgeted and what
you have before you uh corrects that
okay so so we'll end up go ahead
representative thank you Mr White I'm
looking at
status of actions related to hb1
this in front of you and then on the
Family Planning line
is that or maybe this is for Mr Ripple
is that
984.044 was that the agency's request to
adjust down or was that Mr Earth's
Amendment
I guess I'm trying to reconcile the
numbers
I I believe that that was an earlier
version
yeah that that was an earlier version
there's been ongoing work behind that
the the agency request portion was the
um there as has already been identified
there's there's two components here
there's a reduction in the federal
dollars but then there's also the
movement of uh dollars between Class 74
and class 102 to get back at that
sub-recipient contractor issue that
you've heard me talk about a number of
times now
I apologize I mentioned that that's
actually from the Department that both
were combined into here that's what I
was trying to understand because it's
under an agency request so that's why I
was trying to sorry about that figure
out if we connected the dots on what the
department wanted
okay
so bottom line
is is or is the line
16 on the on the status of actions is
that now overcome by events and we
should be just looking at the
spreadsheet proposal of Representative
verf
yes and and the department agrees with
representative Earth's numbers yes okay
all right very good
so does that mean that
we should just cross out line 16
completely you could either cross it out
or in effect we're modifying the numbers
I mean however you want to use your
spreadsheet but but six the 16 numbers
are no longer accurate numbers yes more
than
984. yes that's the way I understand
thank you
okay so let's start string them
represent a string go ahead I I do
notice there's a line item on
residential treatment rates so I would
suggest that we it's a a huge number and
I don't think we've talked about it in
any great detail in here so before
dismissing it without consideration we
probably should add that to the roster
for tomorrow which I'm sorry which one
items 21 and 22 on page two on the DHS
HS prioritize needs I see office of
business operations and management this
is called system of care
but over on the right they they call
funding for children's residential
treatment rates further program detail
and CR document
so I'm oblivious I'm not I think I think
the item that representative Stringham
is looking at on the on the document
that was handed out a few days ago is
now number 10 on the document I handed
out today that reads status of actions
related to House Bill one
thanks
all right so now I'll say to you
representative Stringer what I said to
representative Waller what what how
would you basically characterize the
conversation that you'd like to have
well I think it's it's probably similar
to to the the Medicaid rates type stuff
where is there
is there dramatic need is it underserved
is this uh
does oh to what extent does this make a
difference and um
um you know why they come up with a with
the request that they have
all right and and it looks like it there
may be some potential overlap with some
of the reimbursement rate work that
would I want to make sure that that uh
we understand that if that's the case is
this your shoot yes okay
all right so I want to talk about
um the Edwards amendment to Family
Planning
this is adding instead of in the past oh
you know I'm not ready to do that
on the earth Amendment
uh I I see that the the 24 number house
introduced is 837 508. what what what
what what what I'm missing here is what
was it last year what kind of increase
are we talking about because I remember
the general funds in the 2223 operating
budget were
so this turns out to be decline in
yes is it because there was a lapse that
we're anticipating I'm I I I I know that
we didn't get all the vendors that we
wanted to get and so some of these
contracts didn't get let is there is
there a lapse that happened from the
last budget that we can anticipate or
should sure so just speaking to the
history said the reason that it's 861 in
2022 and 813 in 2023 is because I
believe the fifty thousand dollars that
was provided that that was added there
which is why you saw that increase
um for the prior year for the specific
lapse
um I I need to go and look at the
details I'm not quite sure what that
would look like yeah that that would
just be good to know I don't know if
that's going to affect our budget
decision but but for those people who
are reluctant to put the hundred
thousand aside for the vendors it may
give them some background material what
what what
what has been going on is that
there was language introduced in hb2
last term that essentially said that in
order for
a reproductive health facility
to successfully apply for a family
planning Grant or or contract
they needed to be able to demonstrate
from
um from the abortion services
and
the executive committee
has not accepted a single
has not accepted a single contract I
don't think from
a reproductive health facility I.E an
outpatient abortion provider because
those terms are synonymous
so so as a result instead of having I
think Statewide we anticipated eight
Family Planning contracts
we ended up I think for quite a while
with just four but still
the the the abortion providers are
having trouble getting the executive
committee to look at their contract
proposals
so so we have some holes in our coverage
that I don't think any of us want the
holes and there's a couple different
ways to try to fix the hole the way I'm
attempting to fix it is by creating
a one-time incentive to a new vendor to
go apply for a contract and if they win
the contract then they get like a twenty
thousand dollar bonus and this hundred
thousand is based on the assumption that
we could do at least five additional new
vendors
and in the past budget we did it with
fifty thousand total and ten thousand
per new vendor and not a single new
vendor applied as I understand it so
that fifty thousand is going to lapse
because it didn't get spent
right
okay
so so you you can I just need to just
continue my wandering
okay so so this is my attempt
well I I had also tried to fix the issue
by requiring an audit uh and and that
bill did not succeed I was trying to
give the family or the uh
the reproductive Health Facilities a
pathway to where they could
certify to the executive Council that
they really had Financial Independence
between their abortion operations and
their family planning contract that we
gave them that bill failed
nevertheless I still want greater Family
Planning access and that's why I'm
asking you to support the idea of
putting this hundred thousand aside for
up to five contracts at twenty thousand
each for new vendors this would be a a a
clinic that had never provided Family
Planning services in the past who goes
and successfully gets a contract that's
okay
so that's a lot go ahead representative
are those clinics even a possibility are
there any is there any organization
willing to do that in the current
environment knowing that the executive
council is not
approving certain monies and contracts
those are three questions sorry no no
that's all right but but I do think
there's three three questions in there
when the abortion providers lost the
extent the contract renewals
I was provided information that said
there was a clinic that could provide
replacement services around each one of
them within a three mile radius so there
so the answer are their potential
clinics that have Geographic proximity
the answer is yes the other part of your
question the second question I think is
are there any clinical providers that
want to engage we don't know that answer
but what we do know is none applied so
so what we know is that they're
interested in implying isn't sufficient
to do it for their ten thousand dollar
one-time bonus so in order to entice
them out
I'm trying to raise it to twenty
thousand
and I forget your third question in
there
I don't recall the third question
however I do want to just confirm and
this was before
I was on this committee or got deep into
this so I know what I know just from
news that
um the department was clear I believe in
in showing that to the executive Council
that no
um funds were used on abortion care I
just want to clarify that that is maybe
a year ago or so that that is where we
were at and it still got stalled on the
executive Council
yes we we brought we brought forward
those contracts
um
at least two if not three or four times
for a vote and and those particular
we agree on the facts and one of my
bills was intended to give
the reproductive Health Facilities a way
to strengthen their argument that there
is no commingling of funds and that bill
failed with
the abortion providers opposed when that
bill went to the policy committee well
haven't they been clear that there is no
co-mingling of funds they've said it the
the problem is there are people who
don't believe it and the executive and I
can give you one example of why they
don't believe it if you want
um at a time where New Hampshire was
paying for 20 of the salary for the
executive director of the New England
Planned Parenthood organization we were
paying 20 percent of her salary I think
it was like 260 280
000 years so we were paying 20 of that
she spent a tremendous amount of time in
Vermont lobbying for
um
she would call it reproductive Health
conservatives would call it um you know
you know more more protections for
abortion and I think they wanted to she
was advocating for having it put into
the Vermont Constitution for example so
in that case
citizens of New Hampshire were saying
we're paying 20 percent of her salary to
go help Lobby in Vermont that would be
an example in some people's minds of
commingling
so
because this is
not a completely rational argument that
we have with one another or amongst all
of us
um
I'm just trying to figure out how we can
address it because these Family Planning
services are great Services they need to
be have
STDs Wellness checks for women
you know
the Family Planning program is a great
program I want it picked up and as long
as the executive council is under its
current composition
I think we need to find new vendors or
not and I'm saying yes let's try
I'm not don't want to be suspicious of
your actions but can you
um assure me
that
a first-time contract awardee would fall
there's I see no verbiage that actually
deems what these contracts would be that
they would be providing
um a comprehensive reproductive Health
Care to all persons I guess I'm not
quite convinced that this this bonus is
it's clear in hb1 of what this is going
to go to
so I appreciate your deep cynicism and
I'll try to assure you that I'm not
trying to pull a fast one we did
something similar last budget but with
lower numbers and the way I understood
it to work is that the Planned
Parenthood Services contract is the
contract and vendors bid on that
contract and for them to win the
contract they have to provide according
to the terms of that contract and so so
whether or not they're providing the
full range of Family Planning services
to everyone who would be entitled to it
I would say probably yes but I have
nothing to do with that that's actually
what's in the Family Planning con
Services contract and so so why the
department says that they would be now
whether or not they're a first time
awardee is pretty straightforward did
you have this contract in the past no or
is this first time you've had it yes
then I was told that there was the
mechanism
last budget to go ahead and pull the
trigger and provide them with the ten
thousand
this budget cycle I'm assuming all of
those capabilities are still in place
but I'm I'm upping the ante to pull
hopefully more competition into this
space
I don't know if that satisfies you but
I'm trying to be ethical about it
go ahead I just wonder do you think
there might be other reasons
that
people don't come forward and want to
contract do you really want me I'm going
yes you may
so it's my understanding that very few
of the title 10 Family Planning dollars
are pulled down in general having
nothing to do with the
big a word
Medicaid
funding provides for can be used for
most if not all of the non big a word
family planning services and Medicaid
funding is completely
direct with the federal government we're
not involved in the state and it's much
easier to access
so the bottom line is these title 10
funds for the most part they don't
really get used they don't that's the
last place people seem and by people I
mean those providing these Services tend
to go for dollars they have a much
bigger and easier to access bucket in
straight Medicaid funding and it sounds
like it looks like maybe Mrs
representative wellner agrees with me
at least you're shaking your head yes I
didn't know if that was a good thing or
a bad thing well I mean
yeah it's I mean I think
if there's an easier way for them to get
the funding to provide the services that
are needed then of course I'm not sure
that a twenty thousand dollar bonus is
really going to attract people I wasn't
speaking to the whole bonus thing I was
giving a different perspective on
funding for
I don't want to use non-title 10 if you
will Family Planning Services funded
through Medicaid just that the services
are still there and they're more readily
accessed in other ways as evidenced by
the fact that the Family Planning
dollars don't tend to get drawn down and
not just here in New Hampshire it's a
kind of a general thing apparently
Medicaid funding is easier to access for
okay so I think the answer to the other
question is that we stumbled on earlier
is going to be relevant to this account
and that is what's the what's the
expected lapse because it sounds to me
like we could have a pretty high
expected lapse in general funds
in this account as a percentage so could
would you be able to tell us that
tomorrow sure
okay so we can discuss that or vote on
it tomorrow but but that's the
introduction of what that's all about
that's my desire to do what is good and
right for young families to be able to
do actual Family Planning
um
is there
what was the BR this broken out sheet is
that the sununu sheet no it's family it
says Family Planning that's
true
Mr Ripple did you so the first page was
representative Earth's Amendment the
second was yours and the third was the
Department's original
request to adjust that accounting unit
so it sounds like representative Earth's
amendment has replaced that one
and on that note could I just get some
clarification was representative erf's
Amendment approved or are you holding on
that until tomorrow we're going to hold
on that tomorrow so that there's soak
time representative Waller I want to go
it's can the department speak to whether
or not there were any
people who applied
for the funding
my understanding is no I mean when from
an organizational perspective if you're
a business ten thousand dollars it
probably wouldn't even cover somebody's
health insurance
right so I I I just think that's that's
kind of important when we're thinking
about like whether whether that's
sufficient to encourage organizations to
come to the state
so you had no so the department had no
no applicants no no that that's my
understanding and so um I'm waiting to
verify I'm actually in the process of
doing that right now waiting to verify
whether those amounts like that fifty
thousand dollars my assumption is that
probably lapsed
okay so to clarify you're saying that
there were no new applicants but we did
let at least four Family Planning
contracts and so presumably those were
pre-existing non-abortion provider
vendors
yes yeah those those contracts were
approved and the the others were not
right and and of those four
uh I think
I think a couple of them were in smaller
communities where they weren't going to
be demanding much of the Family Planning
money to provide the services so I I
think it's going to be interesting to
see how much of of this is is available
to labs
okay and I don't know if 20 000 is the
right number I'm just trying to get the
Right theory the Right theory is if you
incentivize Behavior you're going to get
more of it so I'm trying to get some
more people to compete for these go
ahead I just want to make sure that
we're careful when we look at your
Amendment and mind tomorrow that the
yours doesn't override the federal funds
did both we would just combine them
together
and I I don't know why we wouldn't on
yours it's just a technical fix
so we could even do that now I mean rep
do you want to do that now or do you
want to go ahead and wait I I think
representative erf's is just so apparent
and obvious that there's no reason not
to vote now other than we don't have to
until tomorrow all right
okay
you go one item down on the status of
actions related to house build one sheet
you have the prescription drug
affordability board and I have a few
amendments related to that both to House
Bill one and to House Bill 2. and and
did I did did we provide that amendment
to everyone has that been distributed to
the committee yet I have not handed any
of those out oh well that's my mistake
we should handle hand out my pdab
Amendment
okay so I have I have two for you one to
House Bill one and one to House Bill two
and this I have the same for
representative walner she also has one
for each would you like all of those
handed out now all of them for pdab yes
sure
okay just tell us the topic what uh
child care okay we have to be out of
here in about 10 15 minutes because
Janet has told that to security so it's
good it's good to have a forced end
because this isn't going to end
naturally we got more stuff that can be
done
Janet has already told security that we
will be out of the building they need to
know when the building is secure so
they're keeping security around until we
leave so somebody's creating an overtime
requirement for them so where do I put
my sleeping bag
I we got that whole coverage section of
while we're waiting for that Amendment
on
the last item where we're discussing
where there was 647 I believe or
something and then 613 for the Family
Planning I don't know the numbers in
front of me was that fifty thousand
dollars the line item that
representative Edwards was discussing
the reason the Boost in the first year
in that fund
sure so you you're you're referencing
say fiscal year 2022 and 2023. yeah so
it was 861 million dollars of General
funds and 813 million dollars of General
funds in 2022 and 2023 respectively
thanks again thousand right not million
I'm sorry a thousand yes
but I guess specifically the 861 was 50
of that can you tell 50 of that was from
the amendment that representative
Edwards was discussing that may have
been at the beginning of last budget
cycle I'm I'm almost positive Kevin you
don't know if the top of your head do
you if the detailed change we could see
it in the detail change we can verify
Mr chair I guess that brings us up right
we're going from 8 11 and
8 11 and 8 13 to 837 I don't want the
numbers in front of me both here so it
so representative walner do you want to
talk to your hb2 first or your hp1 first
how would you like to go you can go
first though
well hb1 is just um the
um funding that the board
provide they they had a vote and this
was how they built their budget so that
I'm just bringing in what they what they
built as a budget and
the hb2 amendment
basically it just
um changes the funding from the fees
which they were
allowed to assess to a general funds so
this just represents what the board uh
presented as their um
okay
so
um so they want to suspend and I I
forget which one bb-8 is is that the one
where they're uh where they're leveling
fees on the industry
okay so this does not address where they
can level fines
civil penalties
did in your discussions with them did
they say anything about their ability to
no it suspense dash eight
the Civil penalties is dash 10 I believe
oh and that's why I'm asking the
question but I'm looking at yours as the
same one no I'm we're talking about hers
though so I'm asking her the question is
because it sounds to me like they've
listened to jail car and jail Carr has
said you can't do fees because they're
structured this way and it looks like a
tax not a fee so it sounds like they've
come to you and said
based on this maybe they didn't say it's
based on jail car well I think it's
probably based on gel car that that they
don't want to collect these as fees they
want us to fund them from the general
fund
I decided that I would do I would try to
fund it through the general fund and not
through fees okay so to that extent you
and I are an absolute agreement because
my amendment has that component in it as
well that was one reason I went that way
oh oh sure okay so uh now do you want to
no I think it's pretty self-explanatory
it's the budget that the board voted on
okay so this is the the bud the board's
budget but no agency income and all
General funds yes can I ask you a
question go ahead so what does the house
introduce column then if I'm assuming
yours must be the revised budget column
that you're saying was what they voted
on so what's the house introduced
version
the number that was included in the
governor's recommended budget I'm not
sure what it was based on originally but
it wasn't what the board voted on so you
have among the various Department
technical requests one of them was a
revision to this board's budget okay
and it didn't show up in our hb1 because
it came in late but as wait it wasn't an
HP one when it went from the agency to
the governors but one that came out of
the governors that's when they had the
lower number than what the board wanted
and because the statute says
the department has to pass through
exactly what the request is this is sort
of an uh the fir we're the first people
to be able to look at their budget and
determine if it's rational because the
DHHS didn't do it because they're
precluded by law and the governor's
office didn't do that so we're the only
ones the first ones to look at their
very first budget
so okay so we're gonna we'll talk about
that tomorrow what okay so my Amendment
does more than that
um it takes on the same issue that
representative walner did to say that
gel Carr says that the fees and the
statute are really taxes and so rather
than doing the fees we should be doing
General funds instead to me that
suggests that portion of the statute
should be repealed and replaced and so
so my my bill does the repeal and
replace and says we're going to do
General funds here then there are some
other issues you know such as the the
Civil penalties do you want to talk walk
us through this in about
45 seconds
because because we're really getting
and I should know it better than you but
well I believe the first section number
one removes uh the fees and funds the
board entirely with General funds
so two is basically we had testimony
that said I'll help you out and go back
to you but the two was because we had
groups like new Futures and AARP saying
this was a great program and we ought to
invest in it this creates a dedicated
fund that would allow organizations such
as them to put money into this so so
this is their opportunity to demonstrate
their commitment to the program lines 8
through 16. then what do you got for 17
we're just oh we're basically suspending
um for just we're suspending not
repealing their ability to start pinging
the industry for data I believe okay and
section three on lines 21 through 22
repeals the board's authority to Levy
civil penalties right so the Civil
penalties if they make a data request
that isn't answered they can start
finding the entity and every entity a
thousand dollars a day up to a maximum
of 25
000. there is no oversight there is no
due process they just charge the fee of
the fine and start collecting the money
that that that
civil penalties capability is a huge
risk I think to the Future
go ahead
section four removes the ability to hire
an executive director and replaces it
personal services contract is the term I
use that's an old Federal term for you
go hire a contract employee basically
with one or more contract employee
Section 5 requires contracts entered
into by the board to go through the
competitive competitive bid process
right and also requires a
on page two starting on line three that
the board annually report on funds spent
to the fiscal committee all right
and section six requires the board to
collaborate with the insurance
department to issue a report on the
elimination of redundancies related to
the collection of data between the two
entities
now so this redundancy elimination
report that this was a little
complicated because the governor put in
a regulatory reform program that the
governor's office asked be consulted in
this and so I think you wrote this in a
way in which that regulatory reform
program didn't need to be in effect and
we'd still have to create the report at
I think that's correct yes
okay
and then you there's seven and eight
yes yeah
okay
so
um so what my budget does my hb1
is in the first year seventy five
thousand dollars that's enough to go you
know throughout the course of the year
at some point they'll be able to go hire
somebody to to help representative
Merchant run the program and then in the
second year that goes up to a hundred
thousand with thinking that it's
probably funding more towards the full
year so there's more there and then it
gives them some supplemental expense
money so this is much lower than what
they requested and and we can we can
talk about this more and tomorrow we
could because we probably want to get
out of here in the next 60 seconds
could we ask uh representative Merchant
to come down and
be here while we discuss this
sure
yeah I don't know it's availability you
know but I'll I'll talk to him today
yeah
um any other questions comments you have
anything for the good of the cause Mr
Ripple what you know what we're doing
tomorrow we've got some open hb2 items
still we got some HB ones to go over yes
um
yeah because we've all agreed on
everything
tomorrow Wednesday Tuesday
or do we have anything else going on
tomorrow I am I'm lost in the schedule
or is division three the only thing
we're doing tomorrow division three is
and what time do we start you start at
10 o'clock tomorrow 10 a.m okay and um
in Wednesday's session we could not do
anything
oh no we're gonna we're gonna be done
tomorrow because we're out of time
we we even if we have to just force
premature votes we've got to be done
huh
no I mean no it's easy to call a straw
vote and move on the the trick is to I'm
trying to do it respectfully but I know
that we're not going to agree on a lot
of this anyways so at some point
the extra discussion is just time
consuming
right
nope okay so um so with that this work
session of division three is adjourned
thank you